everybody hello hello um welcome to the launch of snow so
far snow sorry so park snow day i swear the more i stream i
guess like my english is deteriorating i i don't know sound
guy is alive today i hear sound guy will be uh oh he is he
is alive type in the youtube chat i see oh okay I didn't
mean to start.
Okay.
Oh, we're starting.
I've had like an intro and everything planned, but like, I
guess we're starting The snowstorm of the century all of
South Park County is being pummeled with snow and more is
expected to come Is it South Park always snowing?
Isn't that the whole thing?
Love did you see how hard it's snowing out dad?
Yes, we didn't know it was snowing when was there any other
weather in South Park?
Right yet this storm has gone from bad to worse
over and a tanker truck has crashed multiple casualties
multiple casualties yeah i didn't know they will but people
are dead that means school's cancelled yay oh god
they're gonna cancel ski
you see
now it's different now instead i think i think i've heard
about this because now that like we're so used to like
online learning from covid even if it's a snow day now
apparently some schools will just transition to like online
learning so they'll be like schools canceled that's okay we
have online learning classes for you to go to instead so
this doesn't matter anymore this was something we used
Back in my day, little Timmy, we had school days where we
actually don't have to do school work.
We didn't have good enough technology for online learning
classes.
Remember what they took from you?
City officials were warning that even first responders will
be staying home today.
The roads are completely blocked.
There is no toilet paper anywhere.
What a bad skit.
the end of days everyone please take care of yourselves it's
okay those people don't matter they're not main characters
all park county schools are closed for the day yay
no school that's a toilet baby
see you later mom i'll be back in a couple hours have some
Nerd!
I'm going outside to play with my friends.
I don't think that's safe, sweetie.
Mom, it's a snow day.
I feel like this is just a react channel now of watching
self-park.
Which I don't mind.
Today we're just gonna be watching self-park episodes on the
Dokeybird channel.
Oh my god.
You're 3D!
Oh my god!
No school!
Yay!
Come on, buddy!
Let's go, Stan!
Snow Day, everyone!
People are dying in the snow!
New kid, I'm talking to you!
That's me!
New kid!
Okay, before like, I accidentally started the game, uh,
before I want to talk about, you know, usually I would have
like, you know, 10 to 15 minutes Zassadon before I actually
start the game.
But then I accidentally started the game.
So we had, anyway, as I was saying, the riskiest part about,
the riskiest part about playing a game on launch and then
not knowing if a game is good or not, I was worried because,
okay, like, I love Self Park.
I actually really like Self Park.
I've been, like, keeping up to date with all the new Self
Park episodes, and, like, I've watched almost every episodes
of Self Park.
I grew up watching Self Park as well.
I shouldn't have, but because, like, my parents didn't
really know what I was watching when I was, like, home
alone.
So then, like, you know, when my parents used to, like, own
a restaurant, They would leave me at home and then self park
will be playing and then I'd be watching it like on TV on
comedy central And I'd be like yay self park and I'd be like
really young.
I shouldn't have you watching it Like I absolutely should
not have been watching self park also also I used to have
like this one of my Parents is like ex-friends anymore but
they had kids too so then like the older sister would like
take uh tricked my parents into taking me to watch the self
park movie um i was definitely way too young for that uh
i had zero understanding of what the fuck i was watching and
then i apparently my parents got When they were, because
then the older sister was like, like my parents ex-friends,
like daughter was like, no, it's an animation.
Like, she can watch it.
And then, so then she tricked my parents to like, because
like she wanted to watch it.
So then like, by doing so, they're like, oh yeah, I'm going
to let Joki watch it with me so that like she's allowed to
watch this movie.
So then they're like, oh, it's a kid's animated movie?
you can totally bring a little dokey over to like watch with
you at the theater so like here's some money here's some
money so you can like treat yourself and watch that movie
with with little dokey and then you know i got taken to
watch the south park movie i like remember bits of it in my
head i haven't rewatched i never rewatched this movie by the
way but i still remember it because uh because because you
know it was like i guess like ptsd because i was way too
young and i i was way too young and i should not have been i
only i watched like music videos of the songs from that
movie recently um but yes i was way too young to be watching
the Park movie but that's that's why I'm like this that's
why I'm sort of like this also ultimate thank you mr.
richard thank you thank you blame Canada blame Canada but
anyway anyway and then so I love South Park I a hundred
percent completed stick of truth I haven't touched the
Fractured but whole self-barking yet because I that was like
a game I really wanted to play on stream, but also was
really worried because like I play stick of truth and I know
like stick of truth was Incred- I shouldn't- I don't know if
I ever want to stream stick of truth on stream because of
how bad it is in terms It's really bad is it's so like but I
I haven't spoiled anything for for Fractured but whole
because like I I don't want it because like this is like one
of the rare moments where I don't want to be spoiled Because
like you have to be surprised like you have to go in
completely blind for that game like for like the self-park
games And so like but the thing is the only thing I know
about the the the fractured but whole game is the diabetes
kid Because like like that's the one of the cutscenes popped
up in my recommended and I watched it It was so good, but
that's the only thing I remember super diabetes.
Yes, that's the only thing I was able to like spoil myself
on But like I have not I don't know anything that's going on
in that game I know it's a sequel to the state of truth, but
like I try I didn't want to spoil it But I don't know if
it's appropriate.
I don't know if it's appropriate to stream Like, that's why
I haven't streamed it yet.
Maybe one day, one day.
Because I know Snake of Truth is so fucked up.
Anyway, I love South Park, and I keep up to date with South
Park.
But the thing about how risky it is to stream games on
launch, the thing is, is that...
Also, apparently we have to turn...
Let me turn down a little bit first.
Is that...
The thing about it is that...
I don't know how good the game is and then I checked the
reviews for this game and I was so sad because it's mixed
reviews I was so sad I was like no the reviews it's mixed
because they they've hit home runs on all their on the last
two games I was like no and okay I don't look okay IGN gave
it a three, but like, it's IGN, so I'm like, I don't know
how much I can trust IGN.
I was like, IGN has said some really weird shit about video
games, so I never really cared much about IGN reviews, but
they gave it a three, and I was like, no!
Why is it mixed?
I'm just like, why?
Apparently, the issue is that this game is very expensive.
Like, that is, like, one of the biggest issues for this
game.
It's, like, it's, like, way too expensive for how long...
It's apparently a five-hour game, max.
Or, like, minimum.
It's...
Oh, sorry, minimum.
It's a minimum five-hour game.
And it's, like, basically, it's supposed to be, like, like,
a hack-and-slash.
It's, like, a hack-and-slash.
and uh people were complaining about how how uh five hours
for like a campaign and stuff but then they're they also
said they're gonna add more to it they're gonna add uh
they're gonna add more to the game later on but then people
were like whoa why is it only five hours because it's
multiplayer there's multiplayer elements to it so we're
gonna see ourselves we're gonna see ourselves why this game
is mixed we're gonna see by the way i bought the deluxe
version so it was not just 30 dollars i you can tell i have
cred you can tell i paid a win i need people to know i paid
a win because i have cred right now wait is cred the dlc i
don't actually know i assume So, I spent...
I need people to know that I have cred.
I'm flashing that cred right here.
Alright.
Okay, I should have...
Okay, I...
Oh my god, it can be a gnome!
Wait, I can be a gnome?
Oh my god, get gnomed.
Every time you look at me, you're gonna get gnomed.
All right.
Oh, wait.
Let's have... Okay.
All right.
Yellow.
Yellow hair.
And then... Do they have... No, they don't.
Okay.
Let's see.
They can't... I don't be bugged.
I can't be bugged.
That's fucked up.
I can't believe I can't be bugged.
Oh, I can be!
Oh, nice.
Guys, I can be.
I can be bugged.
Balding.
That's good enough.
That's good enough for me.
That's...
Balding is good enough, you know.
It's almost like Bald.
I got cred.
I need people to know I paid $50.
I...
I need people to know that I didn't wait for the reviews and
I pre-ordered $50.
I pre-ordered for $50 I need people to know that I am that
shameless I did not read the reviews okay all right let's
see or it could be ginger oh wait I could be a ginger
balding wait it's not offensive because they're not real
people I should be careful I should be careful what I say
Okay, I'm gonna be...
I'm gonna be a ginger.
They have no soul.
It's true!
If South Park says it's true, then it has to be, right?
I take my facts from...
I learn about my news from South Park because they're always
up to date.
Yeah, I'm gonna do...
Oh, you're ever gonna do the soulless.
Oh my god, there's e-boats.
Nice.
That's what I like to see.
All right.
Do they actually have, like, oh my god, they had the Snoopy
dance!
This is it.
This is the real gameplay.
The dancing is the real gameplay.
All right.
I'm done.
Finished.
Is that good?
What is this?
I don't know.
Clapping.
All right, here we go.
I'm good.
I can be ginger.
It's 10 out of 10.
friends don't worry mom ah hello my leash it is i the grand
wizard we have many battles to fight this day oh right by
the way since you last played we had to redo all the rules
and start over because somebody got all op so you're gonna
have to go to the school and talk to the keeper of rules
who's who who got op that can be me find the keeper of the
rules apparently there's like online multiplayer too so w
asd to walk here i'm using my control Let me let me use my
controller No All right guys apparently I'm going to be
using my controller Sorry Apparently All right I'm going to
be using mouse and keyboard like a true PC bro I'm going to
be Okay All right so apparently I need to turn down the
music a little bit All right All right Sound guy Don't worry
I'm turning down my music let me know if everything is okay
if i should make it louder okay i need a remap all right let
me turn down everything all right it's all right i've always
i just wanted to play on mouse and keyboard anyway jesus
christ why is the sensitivity so high okay that better i
love being so a stickler for this there you go that's a lot
better come meet me on the roof we gotta Coming over,
butters.
Is there actually no subtitles?
Okay.
Oh, no, wait.
There actually is no.
Oh, there we go.
I was like, I forgot accessibility.
Okay, there you go.
I was going to be like, where the fuck is the subtitles?
I'm like, okay, I know you don't care so far, but damn, you
don't care about reading.
You actually don't care.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
We have, we can read now.
We can read.
That's so nice.
Are we on Discord?
Oh my god!
We're on Discord!
Okay, how do I get on top of the school?
There's South Park Elementary.
They understand that Doki Cat-Ri.
Alright, here we go.
You can hide in deep snow to protect you from any
projectiles.
And put you all you've been set on fire.
Stay in deep snow too long, however, will chill you with
slows and deal damage.
How do I...
Oh, that's where I could hide.
The discord went over.
Like...
The wizard says toilet paper is more precious than gold
right now.
Pick him up, new kid.
Oh my god.
That's mine.
Use that toilet paper like real money.
Use it to buy a weapon.
It's okay.
He doesn't know.
Oh my god, toilet paper is money?
No, I thought it was over.
Apparently COVID's coming back.
Did you guys hear that?
It's never over.
Bro, this is so fucked up.
All right.
Ooh, weapons.
Oh, Tolkien.
All right, you're armed now, new kid.
Now take out those snowmen to show you our battle ready.
Not yet.
It kind of never left.
We thought it left, but that was just us lying to ourselves.
Okay, and then hold to release for maximum attack.
Oh, nice.
All right.
Bro, wake up.
It's 2020 again.
Oh, upgrades.
But this game is also about using cards.
Each card is a new ability.
And here's your first one.
Where is I?
No.
I...
I thought...
What?
Self-park!
Powers and special skills.
I forgot.
I'm the chosen one.
Powers and special skills you can use apart from your
weapons.
You have gained your first power now.
But later, you can equip up to two powers at once.
Unlock new powers by completing milestones and exploring
South Park.
Alright.
Is there like...
Oh my god, I can float.
No!
Please.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Bro, what the fuck happened to the school?
Holy shit.
I love how like the school looks amazing, by the way.
And then there's me.
looks actually at really I'm sorry but like the background
looks actually really good I just look so I don't look like
I blend well with the background
I this is not fit at all now look kids I know school's
closed but you should be at home doing remote learning no
robot leaning i can't believe it kids today will never know
the joy of a snow day no
no not the but what if i want to be an elf what if i want to
be an elf oh my god what do you mean oh yeah i actually
don't i never dodge okay we got to dodge by shift Okay, that
seems easy.
That's alright.
They're younger than me.
It's called Survival of the Fittest.
If you live through my slashes, you get to go to first
grade.
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait, do I...
Oh, but there's a healer!
He's like a medic!
Is this Souls-like?
Oh, my God.
Finally a Souls-like game I like.
It's not actually Souls-like.
It's like a hack-and-slash, apparently.
Hoop!
How did I miss?
Oh!
I have to let go!
Okay.
Finally, the FPS portion of the game.
Okay, I definitely need to lower my sensitivity, then.
Oh my god, look at me go.
Please.
Please stop running.
Oh, I can stop.
Okay, thank you.
I was gonna say, I don't...
I don't think I'm level up Get some resources Got some basic
weapon skills And reviewed how to handle your cars Now it's
time for one last test Hey, you wanted to see me?
Who's this kid?
Are they playing?
No, not yet Wait, what is this elf doing here?
I thought we hate elves It's not racism Because they just
Go, go, new kid Kick that fucking elf ass I'm sorry I'm
sorry This soap bark makes me A different person Get back
Get back here, elf!
Get back over here!
You're not real, you don't have rights!
You're an elf!
You got slants!
Oh shit!
It was a trap!
They're not human, they don't have human rights!
And elf rights do not exist yet.
Picking this healing totem card will add it to your powers.
Yeah, we can tell turkey all right nice plant a totem that
heals you and your allies for sure oh that's good also sound
guy how has the sound been good so far all right plant a
totem proper oh i get to heal okay e is healing okay well
done by the way your powers aren't unlimited you have to get
pissed off by healing if you aren't pissed off enough to use
your powers just keep beating up yay When they're pissed
off, you're pissed off meters increases by taking or dealing
damage using powers with decreased Oneness if you can't use
power fight with your weapons until you're pissed off again
Nice is that fucking food?
Am I just eating snacks?
Oh shit.
Where are the elves?
Oh shit Where did it come from?
How did I forget?
Okay, I need to remember guys
How do I weapon swap?
I forgot a weapon swap!
I already forgot!
Oh my god, I don't want to use my bow!
What is?
I'll be!
A, where's A?
No, that's not A.
It's moving!
Oh, it's just left click!
Oh my god, it's just left click.
I don't have to do anything.
It was just left click.
Right click was bow and then left click was sword.
Guys, I'm learning.
I should be a game tester.
Alright, there you go.
We're good, we're good.
We can do this.
We are so good at this game.
It's okay, I can't die.
Butter's just gonna heal me forever.
Great, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
The Super Chat is for Elves' rights.
Justice for Elves.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
If a ginger said Elves have no rights, that's when you know
it's serious.
Alright.
Nice.
I should be a game journalist, honestly.
Okay, flying daggers.
Dagger dive does four more damage after 0.3 seconds.
Creates a gas cloud that lingers.
Your arrow stuns distant enemies for six seconds and do 100%
more damage.
Oh my god.
I already have...
Oh, it's a legendary upgrade!
Nice.
I'm gaming.
Thank you, Jimmy.
I really appreciate it.
Now where do I go?
Wait, there's more?
Oh god.
Okay, give me a sec.
I want to use my cool-ass ability.
I can't believe they got actual kids to do this.
Do you know, like, for the kids' voice acting?
Like, Trey gets his child to do the voice acting.
I think they get, like, actual staff kids.
They actually get, like, the staff's children to do the
voice acting for the kids.
Which is, like, you know...
I guess you don't have to pay them.
You just pay yourself at that point.
Yeah, they're actual real kids.
Yeah.
Yeah, his daughter does, like, some of the children voice
acting.
All right, let's get the audio in.
We gotta boost up the sound effect by five, and then bring
down the music by five.
Okay.
Let me know if it's okay now, sound guy.
The cards are dealt randomly, but just between us, I can
reshuffle them for a little bit.
put i always forget the colors i always i always forget the
colors for like what the rarity so i'm so glad that they
actually tell me because i always forget all right bar
escape deals 20 30 percent more damage and pulls enemies
inwards nice but can i not buy it am i poor choose an
upgrade i want this oh upgrade to get oh they're forcing me
to upgrade from what if it's good never mind this is how
powerful it is.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, they know children don't fucking read.
The keeper of the rules dictates the rarities.
But for a little TP, I can make them more powerful.
All upgrade cards have a level each of which offers.
Yeah!
Okay.
Can upgrade rarity for a bribe.
Oh, it's a bribe.
Nice.
Teacher says corruption.
Okay.
Double tapping a target with Boa creates 10 damage.
Six meter blast.
Wait, that's so good.
However, to promote Can I promote it even more?
Ultra legendary!
That's the one.
Nice.
Toki planning to be an IGN Gaitrin.
Look, my only issue is that I don't read.
Other than that.
Oh my god, he's a bigger elf!
Why are they feeding these elf children?
Oh my god, I knew it.
I knew we should trust these elves get out get away from me
look my only issue is i don't read okay like that the moment
i figure out the mechanics i'm like out of game journalism
territory like oh my god there's so many of them there's so
many of them okay don't worry see we got this but it's so
smart though to getting your kids to like get your kids to
do the voice acting because then you're technically paying
yourself, you know?
You're technically just paying yourself so you don't lose
money.
Whoa!
If you don't have full session of 4, these allies will show
up to aid you.
They'll leave once the fight.
If another player joins your session at any time, one of
these other kids.
Nice.
I got free labor.
Look at that.
They get bigger and loud.
So true.
Yay!
TP!
Wait, how do I open up multiplayer so you guys can join us?
Wait, what's the bullshit?
What's bullshit?
Enemy leaders can play bullshit cards during combat to gain
an unfair advantage.
it to only a few uses but they're really powerful just now
cow just upgraded one of his elven swarmers to a vampire
what the there's back there's vampires in my fantasy
mythical shit what is this oh it increased health and new
attacks what if vampires i thought were lord of the rings i
thought there's no vampires in my lord of the rings rip off
Like...
Okay.
Get him.
Team Edward.
The vampires are fantasy.
Yeah, but it's medieval fantasy.
We're being like sticklier here.
That's why it's bullshit.
It's Castlevania now.
So, as you can see, we've had to make some changes to the
game because some asshole who we won't name, Decided to
become all powerful and ruin the stick of truth because I
mean that's different you kid So then we played superheroes
and guess what happened that same someone got all OP again
and fucking ruined that game too And now because of that
someone I thought you're bad at the game Carmen and then
once there were rules Everyone started arguing over the
rules and then we all went to war again Remember with this
new card based system.
You're only as powerful as the cards in your hand and you
only get two to start with Yeah, because aliens are real I'm
sure you'll manage.
Don't worry, I don't need to ruin this game of the game.
Ruin it himself.
Because this is America.
So, you are now the king of two cards.
That's me.
Clyde has information that the elves are preparing to launch
a massive attack on our kingdom.
They've been spotted advancing their forces near Stark's
pond.
We have to take them out before they kill us off.
Oh, and new kid?
This mission will be very dangerous.
So, I'm pairing you with some other new kids who also
recently moved to town.
But keep in mind, you are the real new kid.
Those other new kids.
Yeah, you heard that?
I'm the real one that matters.
Okay, you're the big dog.
Yeah, me Also, I'm going to sign you.
I have Kray at random.
No big deal, but there's a chance I might not give you
number one.
What?
Just know that you're still the best new kid to me.
You're the important one But I have Kray.
Good luck.
How can I not be number one?
I paid like $20 more than the other regular children.
That's actual bullshit.
What's the point of paying worth money if I'm not number
one?
Three plus one.
Why am I always wife number four?
I'm here and I'll show you how to wage war on my behalf.
And bring your friends if they're not pussy.
Okay, yeah.
This is my war table.
You can choose your mission on the map.
And tell me when you're ready to head to the front lines.
If you want to join someone else's game, you can totally
just be a follower.
Okay, sled matchmaking button.
Oh, okay, wait.
I want to talk to the other kids.
Here, take a look.
that you can get.
Select the psycho-rarity to see how they scale.
Okay, and then change levels.
Select the option, train what bothers again by selecting the
tutorial buttons while learning about the books of laws.
Thank God.
Okay, I was like, I actually don't want to do the tutorial.
All right, let's see.
What else is there?
Is this like the lobby?
Oh, hey, Tweek!
Hey, Tweek!
What is this?
Come back with at least 50 pp.
Is that toilet paper?
Weak and I run the shop together.
He handles the finance.
Oh my gosh, so romantic.
I love, I don't know if you guys ever watched the episode
where they like, hook them up, but they actually use like
real fan art, like real like shipping fan art for their
episode.
Like they didn't draw that.
They were like, hey guys, if you're like a Twi Clyde
shipper, send us some fan art so we can, oh my god.
You're the new kid, aren't you?
It's me, Mr. Hunky.
i thought i thought you got phased out i would never thought
c3d mr hanky i don't know how comfortable i am about this
what is it dark matter perks what the is this either way you
can head back to the war table whenever you're prepared and
if you bring it here you can use it to expand yourself past
your limits give it a try Oh, I want to be stronger.
Yeah, I want to be stronger with bows.
We bought our skin three.
Keep taking in that dark matter.
And you'll get more powerful than you can imagine.
And you don't know about Mr. Hanke.
He's the Christmas spirit.
Because we all have a little Mr. Hanke inside of us.
No matter what.
He's the Christmas spirit.
All right.
Let's see.
Armor.
Oh, this is like gear and stuff.
Alright, what's this?
I heard you want to try out some new hardware.
Oh, look at that!
Tolkien!
I'm sure I have at least one new thing for you to take out
into the field.
I've got a ranged weapon for you to try.
Either way, you can head back to the war table whenever
you're prepared.
Not prepared.
Wizard staff on for size.
Wizard staff?
Oh, a lot of fireballs that burn many targets at once
charged up for it.
Oh, I want to try magic.
Come and visit whenever you want to switch things up.
Ah, yes, Tolkien.
It's always been Tolkien.
Do you know, like, ever since the Tolkien episode, they,
like, they, they, like, changed every official, like,
Wikipedia episode guide, like, on, every official online,
um, information about Tolkien to Tolkien.
The moment that episode, this is, like, actual gaslighting.
Yeah, they switched the subtitles, so it's actually crazy
that they went through all that.
Leave the matchmaking.
Okay, hold.
I want Woo!
Okay, and then Hold and release.
Oh, I can, like, do, like, a strong fire blast, too.
How do I leave the matchmaking?
Do I just, like, oh, I just have to queue up and then
release it again.
Man, I think you've been super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mr. Hanky is just talking about probiotics.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tell me when you're ready to head to the front lines.
You can join someone else's game if you want.
Not everyone is cut out for the glory of leadership.
Alright.
Just mark your name here if you want back up that bad.
I want to...
Alright.
We can get started as soon as you're ready.
Alright, I want to host a game.
Host.
Wait, can I...
Oh, chapter one!
We're gonna do super hard.
How hard can that be as a kid's game?
Like, it's a game set in a children's town.
It can't be that hard.
Select a chapter?
Wait, can I not host game?
What the fuck?
How do I host a game?
No!
How do I host it?
Oh, damn it!
Oh, I'm still in the tutorial?
The tutorial never ended?
Like, what?
What do you mean the tutorial never ended?
Wait, where do you?
Oh, there we go.
I'm hosting, guys.
All right, begin hosting.
Okay, everyone can join, but I'm number one, okay, because
I'm the real new kid.
You're not the real new kid.
I don't even know how to... Is that it?
Is that... Let's pick who you're gonna brutalize today.
Did I host it?
Like, it's a tutorial.
You have to pick.
Pre-ordered.
I did!
I actually pre-ordered!
I... I actually pre-ordered for this.
Privacy set to public.
Okay.
Nice.
And I think that's it, right?
Alright.
Anyone can join my game.
Do I have to wait?
Do I have to wait to start this?
Or like...
Or like, is everything already started?
I don't know.
Can people join now?
Guys, guys, are you really going to make me do hard level
all by myself?
I'm the only one who bought the game.
No, there's no other kids.
I am the only new kid.
Current players, me.
Look at that, guys.
these open slots oh my god guys single file chat guys please
one at a time guys oh my god one at a time don't worry you
don't have to take your time chat you know what what please
single file everybody single file I know it's so crazy.
You get to play Snow there.
Hey, hey, hey, we're all here.
Let's go.
We're all here.
What do you mean?
Carmen wait up.
We gotta wait for the dragoons, Carmen.
What do you mean?
We gotta wait for the dragoons?
Guys People were just in a car jam and it was traffic chat.
There was just traffic everybody Yeah Carmen, who are these
asses?
They're my secret army.
The secret army.
Me.
Yes, the army of one.
They're just stuck in the tutorial.
Remember, there's no fighting allowed at the bullshit trial.
This is secret ground.
Yeah, yeah, just get on with it, butters.
Each player lays down a bullshit card so that we can- My
friends are in another school.
I just moved.
I'm a new kid.
They're at another school.
As the keeper of rules, it is my honor to preside over this
bullshit trap.
Begin your selection.
After birth, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Quick and run.
Don't join so she becomes paranoid about how hosting works.
Okay, I need that rare.
I don't have enough TP for upgrades.
Summon a...
What the fuck?
Why are these cards better?
Oh, that's like...
Is that my bullshit?
Your entire team emits noxious fumes to gross out enemies.
Summon that fight for you.
You become invisible.
Okay, I need to summon minions because apparently I'm just
an army of fucking one And a boost to our double daggers
Where'd you get those?
This is your last chance to back off new kid Elven
immortality nature's enemies become giant why do they have
two bullshit?
Is it cuz they're L's fucking O's that's right.
That's why you have no human rights if you ever because
you're not even human Okay, we can see, like, what cards
they have.
Okay, nice.
They literally have two!
Kyle thinks I don't know he's planning something.
They have two cards!
How are you supposed to do anything in all this snow?
What will we do?
There are no supplies.
Give us the toilet paper, Stani.
Give us the toilet paper!
It was fucking elves.
You're even below gingers who have no soul.
All right, here we go.
I can't believe they get two cards!
That's actually bullshit!
Are you okay, sir?
I wonder if there's any, like, people stuck in the car.
What is this?
Scenic Trail.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, to summon this, I have to hold R.
Where the fuck are the L's?
God, I'm by myself.
I don't feel good about this.
Everyone is with you in spirit.
That's good to know, guys.
there in spirit just yeah it's great okay look at that new
kid here come the elves let's find your kids i'm like at
least in what fourth grade or fifth grade i can't tell i'm
like eternally stuck in like elementary school so i'm like
third i'm like fourth or fifth grade but i know these
children are kindergartners that's right that's right oh my
god i have friends they don't have not the main character.
See, I told you!
Guys, I told you!
They were stuck in traffic.
They don't have names because it's a bug, chat.
They don't have names.
It's a bug.
That's why you don't see any names.
Wait, where did they go?
Sorry, they had to go back home.
Sorry, guys.
They had to, like, go home because...
There was like issues with the internet so they have to get
they have to get the internet fixed Don't worry don't worry
I call them reinforcements my new my new dragoon friends are
gonna come over guys don't worry I'm gonna beat this guy up
I don't know there's like fall damage is there fall damage
in this game oh friends I told you they're back they fixed
the Internet!
Internet has been fixed!
Chat!
Okay, I need to put the totem down.
Excellent work, new kid.
Guys, snack break.
Snack break.
Snack break, guys.
Yeah, this is the new self-park game.
Oh, I need to grab some toilet paper.
Why do all these children have toilet paper?
I'm, like, confused about that.
Okay, how do I get up?
Oh, no.
Okay, I have to parkour up here.
Are these?
Yeah, they are.
Alright, who's in my lobby right now?
Tell me right now, guys.
I know you're not lying.
Because these people are real.
I know you're real, guys.
Who's in my lobby?
See?
Broku!
I fucking knew it!
I knew Broku was in my...
That's the guy that's number two.
Choose your upgrade.
Okay, do I have...
I don't have... God, I don't even have money.
Uh, fuck yeah, I'll do extended aura.
It's rare.
Okay, we're gonna grab...
I'm in their game, too!
I told you.
They're just a calm before the storm.
I told you they're real dragoons.
I told you my dragoons who go to another school were real.
Wow, you think it was a super chat?
Thank you, thank you.
So nice of the dragoons to help you on your quest.
I know, right?
You guys didn't see them the law because they were busy,
like, connecting to the...
internet the dragons that got into my lobby they have really
shitty internet so they cut in and out young ones are always
the most vicious oh my god there's so many of the kids oh my
god why are they all else why don't they want to join the
cool human squad goddamn kyle propaganda it got to them
there's always like this like uh question about Like, who
would win?
You versus, like, 100 elementary kids.
Not the bow.
All right, here you go.
It's not even a bow.
It's a fucking...
No, who put bullshit?
What do they do?
Re-animate?
I literally killed one guy.
I like how they put the bullshit thing out.
And it was literally one guy.
That's fine.
That's fine with me.
It was one guy.
I'm fine with that.
Kyle, you fucking idiot.
I only killed one person.
Okay, does this head-head-head him over here?
I feel like bows would be better.
I don't know.
The- oh, I can have my dragoons kill all of them.
My very real dragoons.
Go my very real dragoons.
Wait, are they eternal?
No, they're not.
Do they also get stunned by the mud?
They do.
Okay, we're fine.
It's fine.
I have totem pull.
I don't have... I have totem pull.
Snack break!
They're so real.
They are!
It's just bugging out that the name isn't on there.
Guys, this game literally just came out, chat.
This game literally just came out.
There's like, you know, there's features there that's not
properly implemented.
So, like, day one, day one...
No!
I'm just gonna use my fucking heels again!
We just gotta accept that day one is not perfect.
They're just undamaged.
Yeah, yeah, there's stream sniper mode on.
I had stream sniper mode on.
So, oh, the golf kids?
Why are the golf kids here?
Do you seek the powers of those beyond our plane?
Oh, Henrietta.
Hey, Doki, you're so cool.
Can I borrow $30 for us to get with a super kid?
chat thank you thank you all right what do you want goth kid
hey jimmy asked for my help with your like game or whatever
these are dark ritual cards they can manifest power beyond
the mundane but some of them come at a price it's up to you
what you're willing to sacrifice for wealth and power anyway
go ahead and like pick one what is this bottom list
replenish all zero expended bullshit uses.
Drainage powers of deception.
Raise the love of all upgrade cards by one.
Sacrifice extended door.
Wait, what?
Dark aura for 60 dark matter.
Do I want dark matter?
I feel like raise the love of all your upgrade cards.
I feel like I don't really need that.
Like, my dragoons will be fine.
Sacrifice to the darkness.
Nice.
There's not much to do around here.
That's fine.
DJ my very real dragoos don't need extra healing okay I'm at
Stark's pond my very real dragoos will be fine hard
difficulty is for babies fucking calling me journalist mode
what is this whoa wait where do I go why is there can I go
to the ice very they're real no one believe me my dragoons
go to another school in canada sorry in america my very real
dragoons in america oh thank god you gotta help me randy
lord i got stuck in the eyes but i hit the jackpot look look
at all this toilet paper i got a way to break the ice and
get me out of here wait he has a nose elven treasure this
looks like a trap i bet kyle's behind this uh yeah kyle yeah
i can help you get kyle just get me out of here i'll give
you some treasure too i'm not oh no he's stuck this is
integrity farms randy or or oh or pre integrity i'm gonna
say it i don't like integrity farms randy i miss old randy
find gas and keys where is The fuck is... Why can't I just
burn him out?
I have fire.
I actually... I miss old Randy.
I think Tegrity Farms Randy is like...
They pushed too hard on the character.
No DLC in this standard.
Wait, what's that?
There's like stuff here.
There's like stuff over there.
What is that?
Is that bowling ball?
What the fuck is that?
Wait, that is a bowling ball.
Elves must have run off somewhere.
Did I not...
Free this?
This is literally fireball magic.
It's real fireball magic.
Yeah, I miss old Randy.
I think that's like one of the changes I didn't like with
the new self-park.
Like, I'm like okay with new self-park, but like Integrity
Farms, Randy, was just too much.
I think they did like...
I think it ruined the Randy character for me.
Because they tried to make him like...
Because now they just...
It's just too much Randy.
It's too much Randy.
But it's not like good Randy too.
What are you doing?
You barbecuing?
Wait, how do I do this?
Entering campsite.
What the fuck was the bowling ball for?
I don't know what the bowling ball for.
Do you want to tell me where your secret base is?
No.
Damage.
Fine.
Kick all their asses, you kids.
Me and my virile dragoons are gonna kick your ass.
They have shields now?
What the fuck?
Dragoons!
My very real dragoons, where are you?
What?
How are they doing that?
Guys!
Oh, nuts!
There you go!
I know you guys were here!
I knew you guys came here!
I knew you guys were in real!
I told you!
I told you they're real!
The internet cut out.
Like, it was an internet issue, but they're here now!
They're here now, chat!
Look!
Look, there they are!
There they are!
The dial-up!
It works!
Sorry, a lot of them are on dial-up right now.
Mom had to use the phone!
Mom had to use the phone, but they're here now.
Remember Randy was on Wheel of Fortune?
No, not on the Wheel of Fortune.
No.
Okay.
All right, get over here.
Get over here.
I'm trying my best to kill the Healer Dragoons.
What are you trying to say?
Australian Internet.
Yeah, yeah.
One of them is on Australian Internet.
The other is on, like, dial-up.
And then the other two, they're using data right now.
play in america so like that's why they're cutting in and
out i have to like wait for them my very real dragoons aol
dragon yay we gotta find the key oh wait there's like toilet
paper here toilet paper toilet paper nice all right toilet
paper they're in the tunnel yeah every time they disappear
they're like they're going through a tunnel chat it makes
perfectly sense.
See, oh no, they drive straight, drove through a tunnel
again.
Ziplining is stupid.
Elves are stupid.
It all makes sense.
Don't get distracted by the zip lines.
They look way more fun than they are.
The elves probably hit the keys in the back near the office.
Wait, why are they hiding Randy's keys?
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god.
Dragons!
Get out of the tunnel!
Oh!
Drago, it's the tunnel!
Oh my god!
One of them's out of the tunnel now!
Nice.
Look at them.
They came out of the fucking... You can tell they were in
the tunnel because they just suddenly lagged in.
You can tell.
Look at that.
They're back.
Ow!
What?
What the fuck was that?
Oh, it's the magic!
It's the magicals.
Okay, don't worry.
I have don't worry where the fuck are the other wait where's
it why do I only have two friends wait why do I only have
two friends do I only have two viewers me and my two viewers
that's fine that's fine even if Doki has one fan I'm one of
them if Doki has zero fans it's cuz I'm dead Only the real
homies are here.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta get over there.
How the fuck do I get over there?
Oh wait, there's the Gob Kid.
I don't know.
That's a real goon right there.
Okay, we got...
Oh my god, fucking hiding in the snowman?
Those are...
Those are elf tactics.
Fight me like I was!
real human that's fucking right so real okay wait how the
fuck did this dragon get up there how did you guys get up
there all right let me grab some loot real fast all right
let me grab this and then talk to the golf kid hello i would
like some upgrades please Ravens grants 20 dark matter
replenish all zero grants a hundred toilet paper Okay, a
hundred toilet paper Remember the real power comes from wait
number two has a name Oh my god, I mean they were I mean
Told you it was a bug I knew they were real all along What
do you mean he's actually real?
They've always been real.
They've always been real chat.
What the fuck do you mean?
Oh my god, they hot fixed it chat.
They hot fixed a game now you can actually see the names Is
that fucking crazy?
Where the fuck am I going?
They're real I told you no one believed my dragoons that go
to school in America No one believed Well, it sucks to be
them.
Wait, who the fuck is this guy?
There's an invisible elf.
There's an invisible elf right here.
We will be fine.
We collected the keys.
We can leave now.
Let's go.
Wait, it snowed in.
We can't leave.
Never mind.
Apparently we actually have to kill all these guys.
Alright, give me a sec.
We have to apparently kill all of them.
I knew it.
I fucking, everyone called him crazy.
Everyone fucking called me crazy About my dragoons that go
to school in America Alright, nice Is that all of them?
No, we have to kill all these elves What the fuck wants to
be an elf?
Oh my gosh, how do I get over there?
How do I get over there?
Oh my god, how the fuck do I get over there?
Okay I did it.
This is it.
We got this.
We got this, my real dragon.
We're gonna do this together.
Alright.
No, the shield.
If you can't deal with your people, maybe you can get a
friend who can.
What do you mean?
I can deal with this.
I thought I was feeling it.
Okay, nice.
We got this.
Okay.
You know what?
I think I might have to use.
I think I have to use this.
It's bullshit time.
Oh, victory.
We did it.
All right.
All right, now.
It's okay.
They're moral support.
We have the moral support.
My moral support crew.
Where the fuck is the exit?
I'm lost already.
I'm already lost.
I have time to go home and pee what the fuck no you're not
paid to pee Number two Number two, where do I it's like code
name kids next door.
Where do we go number two?
Where do we go not is it really there's no way it's this way
Come on, my very real dragoon Where the fuck do we go?
We oh there's like oh shit wait there's crosshairs that tell
us where to go you're so smart all right what can we upgrade
uh let us upgrade fully charged cost five health yeah no uh
damaging bleeding enemies makes you 38 percent more pissed
off the staff now fires three orbs okay we actually know.
It's like reduced 66% damage.
I'd rather just get this and upgrade.
I'm going to upgrade this.
Alright.
Damaging, bleeding enemies make you...
50% more pissed off.
Let's go.
I want to be more angry.
What did we get?
Pool expanded?
Nice.
We got more of the pool.
We got to get the gas.
There's a cannon.
Now you can break that block of ice with a cannonball.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that's how you break the fucking ice block.
Oh, okay.
Wait, where's the bowling ball?
Let me grab some toilet paper real fast.
I can't believe these people will throw away good toilet
paper in the fucking trash can.
They're the new currency.
Gnome gaming.
You always get gnomed.
All right, with this, throw this.
here search how I throw the bowling ball like do I throw the
bowling ball like no my very real trap no it's he's he's
like in the tunnel he's in a tunnel chat guys he didn't
leave it's the internet throughout moments they didn't leave
it It was just the internet, chat.
It was just the internet.
It's the internet.
Where the fuck do I drop the bowling ball?
There's a cannon?
Where's the cat?
There was a cannon here all along?
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
god damn it it's okay i know your internet caused you to uh
disconnect it's okay you have plenty of time to rejoin me
yeah my very real dragon all right oh that's the cannonball
all right let's pick it up and put it in oh yeah oh god i
should walk up the stairs i can't believe it's like i'm a
It's like I'm a child.
I can't believe I actually have to walk up and can't even
jump.
Alright, load.
What the fuck do I shoot?
This?
Oh!
That's what I shoot.
Okay.
And then grab some more.
Oh, we could have another cannonball.
There was a cannonball right there.
I did not have to walk this far.
Free birthday presents.
Get them.
Yay!
For me, it's my birthday.
Do you guys know that?
Because every day is my birthday.
Yay!
Nice!
What I've always wanted!
Toilet paper!
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why would elf tracks lead to a waterfall?
What is this?
Overlook point.
What the fuck is that over there?
What is that over there?
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, I got more dark matter.
Is this lady okay?
I posted my broken leg on social media.
And he got so many likes.
Bro, what the fuck?
Oh, no.
She's an influencer.
We don't go near those people.
Jimmy, look away.
That's an influencer.
Don't go near them.
Alright.
She's fine.
She's just influencing.
Grab the gas can, you kid.
It's right there.
Alright, I'm gonna grab it.
Well, you're fucked.
Oh, no.
It was a trap.
Who would have thought it was a trap all along?
I can't believe it.
How could we have known that?
How could we have known that it was a trap?
Okay, nice.
We're okay No, no, please not be reanimated.
No No!
Times 11!
Oh, it's okay.
My very real dragoons!
Go and do your thing!
You'll be fine!
You'll be okay!
I'll go deal with the archers!
Alright.
Remember me!
I think matchmaking is only the location lock.
Wait, is it really?
my god that's funny you gotta be canadian to play with me i
guess except for my very real american dragoons i got an
exception except for the the very real american dragoons
those are actual americans those are actual it's okay All
right, we gotta...
Don't worry, we're fine.
We're so fine.
Teammate down?
That's okay.
My other dragoons can save him.
Oh, God.
I need a heal.
Whoa.
Oh!
Save me!
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
I told your hard difficulty is nothing.
It's fine.
Revive them!
Oh, wait.
I'm already getting healed.
That's fine.
it's okay then you guys can play with all the other dragons
all right where's my teammates oh he's over there all right
there you go we're fine yeah look at all this beautiful
toilet paper
yay well they're in the tunnel again
Every time, every time the fight is over.
What a coincidence.
They're in the tunnel again.
Guys, what a fucking coincidence.
Oh my god!
How the fuck are you already so?
What the fuck, you have a shield?
This man played a game before I played a game.
Here's what fate has in store.
What do I have?
Uncommon.
It shoots to...
You know I'm going to reshuffle.
I don't like these cards.
Are these more to your satisfaction?
Uncommon.
Enemies drop.
Oh, money!
Yes!
Can I promote it?
Yeah, I'm going to promote it.
I'm going to bribe him.
Now, 90% more toilet paper!
That's so much more toilet paper.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Atoki, I need about 350.
the super chat thank you thank you all right i'm ready i'm
ready to travel where are we oh we're back you won't leave
me like the other dragoon right wait wait before we do that
we have to wait there's a chest i'm bowling ball in the
chest give me a sec here you go oh my god look at all this
all right i got everything we need we need to put the gas in
the can wait did you already do it did you already do it
dragon oh no i have to deliver it to start the goddamn truck
already how do i start it oh i start the truck it's okay i
have a license i got it when i was seven nice what the fuck
i thought he was like in the water Randy.
Are you okay, Randy?
I used to meet you.
Finally, you did it.
Under my guidance and sage-like wisdom.
Oh, thank God.
You did it.
You saved me.
I've been trapped in here all day.
I would have gotten out, but there's a level 3 Elven lock on
that door over there.
What?
I'm so happy.
I found this chest full of toilet paper.
Everyone in town is hoarding this stuff.
Especially that damn stotch.
It's worth more than money.
I'm rich.
I'm richer than stotch.
hiding uh yeah kyle yeah i can show you where he is but uh
oh man i've been stuck here so long i really gotta go take a
shit just uh look within yourself and you'll find all the
answers you need you know believe in yourself and all that
stuff it'll be revealed i'm gonna go take a shit and rub
this toilet paper in that fucking stodges face what this is
the end for you they fucking locked us in ambush make them
regret it you kid they're taking the high ground dumbass
just jump over it I can fucking farm my way out of it.
I don't understand.
What's the point of having the fucking chosen power?
Like, holy shit.
It's like the The ants are right.
It's like it's like Mr. Adult Man right there looking
heading to the movie theater Holy shit, but oh fuck not not
the ants.
No Okay We're gonna...
Roo!
Here we go.
We don't need health.
We're gonna live forever.
It was at this moment.
Doki real.
What the fuck?
Holy shit!
I almost got fucked up there.
Bro, don't mess with trees.
They give us tree powers.
They give us toilet paper.
Don't mess with the trees.
Okay.
We have healers though.
We're good.
Oh my god, you got magic wand.
Bro, he's actually dead.
Wait.
Oh no, that's just his makeup.
Okay, I thought you burned him into a skull or some shit.
I was like, oh my god, that was going to be hardcore.
Hi, they're so...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, they're so strong.
They're so strong.
Oh no, heal me.
The chosen one.
Number one.
It's okay, I'm getting healed.
You guys do all the work.
I'm gonna get healed right now.
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna stay there All right, it's
fine.
Yeah, I don't care about this UFO because it's cannon All
right, we gotta get rid of the fucking arrows All right,
here we go.
This is it.
That's fucking right.
You can't fucking fuck me up this time I can dodge.
What's a super size?
Oh, he big.
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
Yeah, I'm just gonna start using my...
Oh, what the fuck?
Why is this paladin so fucking strong?
The power of the elf guys.
Bro, I'm like so fucking...
Did he like one-shots me?
Oh, no.
I need to I need to stay within this range.
It's okay My dragoons is gonna do stuff.
I'll just go fucking right click I'll just don't get
involved.
I Don't I won't get involved anymore.
Oh no the trees the trees are coming It's alright.
I have fire fire power and my flower power right here Man
that level 3 oven lock really locks you in glad I mean take
it with a super Watch out, thank you, thank you.
All right, I just need to figure out my aim here, though.
Oh my god, what is the drop?
No, not the trees.
Get me away from the trees.
Not the trees.
Oh, wait, he's still alive.
Look, him and the cow is still alive.
Where is he?
Oh my god.
got him they got one of them mr.
adult man it's okay we can solo him that shouldn't be hard
we can solo him trust me as long as he doesn't touch me
we're fine you pew pew pew oh pew wait you did oh i'm dead
warlord wait you're dead oh no i'm floating i'm floating
don't float stop No!
No!
Where's our NPC?
It's okay.
I'm hiding down here.
We're fine.
We'll be fine.
Just revive us in here.
They don't know!
No!
NPC!
Yes!
Revive us in here!
I mean, I mean, real person real person real goon i'm back i
knew i was back i mean the real goon guys i meant the oh my
fucking god why is everybody so strong it's okay it's okay
it's because he was playing so bad that i called him an mpc
chat That's why I called him NPC Because he was playing so
fucking shit Like you don't understand I can't believe it
Hard is actually hard Who would have thought Who would have
thought hard was really hard Guys Jesus Christ I need it I'm
gonna call for bullshit It's bullshit time It's bullshit
time Bullshit please Oh god, I need to heal myself.
Jesus Christ.
Get over here.
Where the fuck are you?
Holy shit.
I can't believe you survived that.
We did it.
Oh my god, we did it.
Who would have sunk?
We survived.
Don't worry.
I can unpick this level three pick.
Jimmy, what are you doing here?
You could have unlocked this door this whole time?
The staff orb bounces twice impact doing...
Oh, wait, I like that.
It does a double bounce.
See you.
Bye.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I need to grab this toilet paper.
And the enemies drop.
Oh, 100% more toilet paper?
I'll be here all week.
or at least until school reopens that's like a hundred
percent more money be careful this is you don't get it there
are rules
holy shit these trees these trees man oh my god it's the elf
king it's kyle that fucking elf
you see you're not a real king a real king will stand behind
lines and then make everybody else do all the work for him
just like cartman's that's why he's a real king oh shit okay
that was on me that that was holy how do i get to you oh oh
i got him guys it took me 20 years but i got to him finally
it took me a while A real king will stand behind enemy lines
and make other people do the dirty work for us.
That's why Carmen's my real king.
Right here.
Jesus Christ, why is this boss fight so hard?
Holy shit.
Why is it so...
I can barely get to this fucker.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Hard mode is actually hard mode.
The moment I get to him, he's already, like, traveled 20
meters away from me.
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
I'm just gonna predict.
I'm gonna do some fucking prediction shit.
Okay, he's gonna...
Oh, he's not moving.
Okay, where is he gonna move?
Oh, he's over there.
I fucking knew it.
I knew you were gonna be over there.
Are you serious?
Where did you go?
That's okay.
No, it's not.
Why am I here?
That's okay.
He has to go here.
No, he's not.
He's over there.
He's over here.
Oh, my god.
I'm fucking activating bullshit.
I don't have bullshit.
Where did he go?
Kyle, please!
Let me at least fucking hit you one time!
I don't care!
Alright, here we go.
Oh no.
Okay.
I need heal.
Please.
No!
That's illegal!
This is illegal!
My fucking snack time!
You don't hit a person!
it when it's snack time those are kindergarten rules you
never hit somebody during snack hours where did he go where
the fuck okay there he is heal heal heal heal heal heal heal
it's so dishonorable okay oh no oh no here we go we're okay
we're Okay, it's still snack time hours.
Nice.
We got him.
He's running.
He's a coward.
He's so scared.
Oh, I'm so scared.
Snack time.
He can't teleport anymore.
He's scared.
He can't teleport.
We can do this.
He lost all his powers.
Go after him.
Oh, he teleported chat.
Who would have thought he teleported?
Who would have thought?
Oh my god, he's one bar.
He's one bar.
This is it.
Woo.
Oh my god, please, please get closer.
Please.
Please, he's one hit.
He's literally so close to dying.
Oh, one hit.
Dive into that.
I'm just gonna use my staff.
Where did he go?
The planet is against you.
No!
She's got this.
I got this!
I've got it!
Yes!
Easy.
So fucking easy.
Yes!
Yes, I did it!
You know what, Kyle?
I learned something today.
You're a little bitch.
Fuck you, Carmen.
Yay!
We did it.
We killed Kyle.
Yay!
Why are we going to meet Kenny?
Why are we going to meet Princess Kenny?
There's a chest!
Okay.
Snack break.
I'm going to open this chest first.
We have a little snack break.
Alright.
Is there, like, any more loot that we're missing?
If you guys knew the slow one is, you should just, like, rip
on them.
Is there any more loot?
I think we were fine.
Alright, I'm coming over.
No!
Yeah!
You picked up a bunch of dark matter.
Hi, Madden.
We did it.
I knew we were gamers.
Look at that.
Look at all these fucking achievements we made together.
Me and my real dragons.
Proceed.
What the fuck does...
Oh, dark matter.
I got the most damage done.
Look at that.
I had the most DPS.
Yes.
Is it lorita?
Well, well, well.
You just thought you could do anything you wanted, didn't
you?
You just thought you were so smart.
I beat you, Cal.
And now by rule, you have to follow my rules here at Coupa
Keep.
Those are the rules, right, Your Honor?
Those are the rules.
Yes.
You didn't beat me, fat ass.
The new kid did.
And who are those other three kids they were playing with?
Oh, those were the other new kids.
Yeah.
They all think they're the actual new kid, but... Yeah, I'm
the one that matters.
I'm number one.
That's why I'm always the host.
You're all just minor copies of me.
Why did you attack my fucking base?
Attack your base.
Ha!
Are you denying that you were gearing up your entire army to
attack our fucking base?
Yeah.
Yeah!
Says who?
Says Clyde.
Yeah.
And do you always trust what Clyde says?
Yeah, because he's not our elf.
Yeah.
Goddammit, you guys.
We are gearing up to attack someone else.
Someone who I think is a real actual friend.
to our town what worse than elves don't you and ginger is a
snowstorm this big in one weekend have you ever seen
anything like it what are you suggesting elf it isn't
natural i think that someone has cast a level 10 endless
winter spell that kind of magic has been outlawed ever since
the new kid ruined the last game by farting backwards in
time yeah well it's been done i know it and what i believe
to have cast this who would do such a thing the same person
who's Stan has been acting strange.
Ever since he thought his version of the rules were best.
Where is Stan?
Must be Man Bear Pig.
But then the new kid came and got in the way.
Wow, nice going, new kid.
What?
What the fuck did I do?
There's been no fun and games for you guys, but this storm
isn't going to end.
And our town is in serious trouble.
Oh, geez.
Then we have no choice.
New kid, we must get to the Marshwalker.
And find out what he's been hiding.
Stan's gonna be evil?
You're loaded with dark matter.
Oh my god.
Integrity Farms fucked him up, man.
Alright, it's time to go to the lobby.
Oh my god, now he's part of my team.
Looks like your mystical powers have grown.
About time.
Go to Tolkien.
Let him guide you.
Oh, I got new powers.
Where are my new powers?
So, now that your powers have grown, let's take a closer
look.
Alright.
Select the powers tab.
Select the power to equip.
Oh, I can have, like, new powers now.
I don't have to heal you guys anymore.
Fast yourself.
Okay I'm gonna Actually, I feel like I'm gonna have to shoot
an eye out for more power.
The fuck is the cat out there?
All right, what what kind of I'm not so good with magic
myself be wild areas and flames Oh my god, this is the one
that you have the token sent you my real dragoon
flamethrower actually i don't know i'm gonna try this i want
to try a flamethrower got weapons here that seems really
cool create a shield all right nice i have a shield now all
right hey guys
hey guys i know you guys so want to play got dragons one at
a time dragons one at a time in this very
Whoa, I didn't fucking look cooler.
Okay, I have 60 PP.
Okay, but like, I don't know, but like, I already have cred.
I need people to know I pay the extra $20.
I need people to know that.
Ooh, I could be like...
like, I can have a tiny crown.
No, but I want people to get gnomed.
Alright, let's see.
I could...
Wait, what is this?
Is that the capes and stuff?
Oh, the emotes!
Wait, how do I even use emotes?
Just buy what speaks to you.
Wait, what is this?
How do I see...
Okay, let's see.
Oh, swifting.
What the fuck is swifting?
Purchase Gola, Tantrum, Twinkle Toast Spin, tap dance I'm
gonna buy I'm gonna buy Swift I'm gonna buy Swifting I don't
know what Swifting is alright how do I use my emotes guys
how do I how do I use
you guys know how to use the emotes in this game
is a T is that Fortnite B?
How the fuck do I use the emotes?
Okay, we're gonna have to Remap controls.
Okay, use bullshit What the fuck is Toot?
Oh, Emo Wheel Z!
Okay, what the fuck is Toot?
Oh Okay, I found the Toot button Yay!
Got $20 Guys, I figured I figured Guys, I figured out what
Toot was.
Okay, wait, what's this?
Oh, I can be Snoopy.
And then, look at me go.
I'm so fucking happy.
Toot toot to live.
All right, let's see.
What do we upgrade?
I feel like we need more HP.
And then, you can get 20% more pissed off.
Nice!
Nice, I have issues.
Let's go.
Let's go Never see Cal Let's continue having problems
Alright Hey guys Like I said One at a time Matchmaking is
open everybody
Alright Oh this is like all the cards That I currently have
Like I said everybody One at a time Okay I know there's so
many people that want to join us.
Slow down, dragons!
Slow down!
Alright, here we go.
I'm ready.
I'm gonna get over here at Death Warlock.
Get over here.
Fine!
We'll have it on hard.
Time to set a battle plan.
All right, start the run.
I'm ready.
Get over here.
Warlock, get over here!
I can't start the mission!
So you're stuck waiting because of one inconsiderate at all.
Yeah!
Guys!
One at a time, guys!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is this guy?
Where the fuck?
Yeah, believe he's creeping you.
Bro, where the fuck are you?
Bro, move!
Get out of the tunnel!
Okay.
Guys, death war.
like it's in the tunnel right now.
Oh my god.
Guys, okay.
I hate to do this.
I hate to do this to you.
But I have to I have to start my lobby.
I need to start the lobby.
And you have to put him down.
Don't look.
I took him behind the barn.
Endless winter spell.
Magic far beyond his primitive mind.
I had to take him outside, didn't I?
I had to take him behind the barn.
Don't worry, he's gonna come back.
I took him to the farm downstate.
Alright, he's at the farm downstate right now.
Alright, here we go.
The Hydra revealed that the Barbarian King Stan and the
Marsh Walkers casted a bad endless winter spell.
He must be stopped.
Dragos.
I know you're all stuck in that traffic jam.
I know you're all in that tunnel chat You're all in that
fucking tunnel right now, but please don't overload the
servers chat Don't don't don't don't overload the servers.
I know it's so hard hard in demand
What the fuck is it?
Cartman you don't belong here.
Fuck you I'm the Grand Wizard.
I belong everywhere.
Since, we know you're not going to win this because your
fucking army are not even relevant characters in South Park.
There's a rumor he's using banned spells.
I'm the wizard.
I'm the only one that gets to use banned spells.
Why don't you and I just settle this now, Cartman?
One on one.
Whoever wins gets to decide the rules forever.
Enough!
I mean, we ought to lay out the Grand Rule so we can get
started.
So go ahead and lay out your cards.
Okay, I don't really have a lot of cards.
Oh!
The wand cast chain lightning for...
I got chain lightning!
I got chain lightning.
That's pretty OP.
Uh...
You become invisible and healed up while cloaked.
Your entire team emits noxious fumes to grow so you can jump
higher, run forever, and move faster.
Okay, that's a lie.
Like, it runs out.
If I can use it five times, it means I can't run forever
Like, what the fuck?
It should be one use if I can run forever
Alright, let's see I am I think I'm gonna go with the I'm
gonna go with this one That should like That should like
hurt All of us can hurt them Okay You can't run forever five
times.
We can't handle.
Remember, you brought this on yourself.
Cursed arms.
Cursed?
You hear melee weapons become useless?
What the fuck?
These are the tools of our rage.
Three, four cards, five cards?
A plus ten axe, you can't do that.
Yes, I can do it.
I forged it by completing a quest.
It's totally legal.
Oh, he went to Home Depot.
Damage grab is a plus 10 axe legal.
What?
Kenny?
Okay, who the fuck is...
Oh, no, it's like, that's not Kenny.
So, we're still gonna beat the shit out of you.
Ask Kyle how my plus 10 wizard balls taste because you're
next.
This is bullshit.
Fucking five cards.
Son of a bitch.
I can't be on the front of the line, but I'll be in the back
casting spells and doing wizard sheds to keep you all safe.
Where's my 50 million power?
Alright.
Where do I go?
It's okay, guys.
Don't worry.
The drag who I kicked is definitely coming back.
He still has one more hour of the game.
Oh, I have like...
It's hot.
It's not like fire anymore.
It's like electricity.
Oh, I see.
Wait, this is so OP.
Look at this.
This is actually so OP if I hit the shot.
If I hit the shot, it's so OP, chat.
I swear.
If I hit it.
There you go.
I just electricity forever.
And I like...
Okay, yeah.
I just need to wait for the charge.
I just do this.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
It's still OP, even if I miss.
It's still OP, okay?
It still works.
Pew, pew, pew.
God damn it.
Pew.
Alright, what the fuck is that?
Pew, pew.
Who made that sound?
Where did that sound come from?
Do you guys hear that?
There was no bicycles next to me.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
God, I'm so good.
Nice.
Hard mode is nothing to me.
She's losing chat.
What do you mean?
I am perfectly okay.
Alright.
I went to therapy yesterday.
Alright, nice.
Alright, dragoons, get over here.
Dragoons.
I need you over here.
right now okay i need a heal too i need a snacky break time
oh is that dynamite bro is that fucking who gave you
dynamite what is that oh my god they have fucking dynamite
that's a waste of good toilet paper oh oh my god Those are
those are not elementary school students
Sad Gonna just let your buddy get smothered, bro.
The elves are working for them, too Oh, they're fireworks.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
San got the illegal illegal kindergartners Let me go Let me
go!
He got the sixth graders!
Where am I?
Am I stuck?
Holy shit.
I need to get out of here.
Oh my god, I need to get out of here.
Who told me to do the hard mode?
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
How did this game get like?
How did the difficulty spike become like this?
Okay, pew, pew, pew, pew.
we're good we like four enemies at once so we got extra
bonus achievements oh god oh god the sixth graders oh my god
the sixth graders are here nice you can't be invisible when
i have my magic wand oh the hockey players the sixth graders
are coming the consequences of my actions oh no that was a
bad so yeah we're good We're good.
It's like my...
It's like my fucking dainty wand does nothing.
We have to kill him together!
As a team!
He hasn't hit puberty yet!
We can take him down!
Oh, nice dark matter.
Wait, what's over there?
Is there a secret?
Oh, there's a secret elf.
There's a secret elf.
No honor.
Oh, God.
Wait, he, like, life steals, too.
Okay.
I'm just gonna do this, and then zap in from right here.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Jesus, crazy.
So tanky.
He's actually so tanky.
There you go.
We have to make sure he doesn't life steal, because he's
been, like, living forever because of that.
Hey, it's toilet paper.
Did we kill the sixth grader yet?
Oh, no.
Oh, no, he's still alive.
Pew, pew, pew.
Wait, what?
You suck.
Wait, did he...
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Who taught you that word?
Whoa!
He cussed in my Christian...
Christian friendly game, by the way.
He cussed in my very Christian friendly game.
I can't believe.
He said a no-no word.
Girls?
Oh no.
Guys, I'm very nervous.
I didn't know girls would be playing would be playing
Dungeon and Dragons.
I'm so nervous.
Bullshit!
What's the bullshit?
Oh, it's fine.
I've been using my...
Your weapons are cursed.
From sticks to kind of floppy snakes.
That's okay.
I've never been... I haven't been using anything else
anyway.
Oh shit, no, not the children.
Alright, pew, pew, pew.
What were my bullshit?
Okay, then...
Yes, okay, I don't need to use it yet.
I'm gonna use one of them for Stan.
the marsh walker okay we need to get over here no i almost
used the melee
all right we gotta get rid of the fireworks the fireworks
are people are actually really annoying no hey i can't fly
out there
hey free food oh my god i can't believe it i have to walk
all the way up here.
Like a fucking peasant.
Pew, pew, pew.
I can't believe I had to walk.
Like a fucking child.
I am the chosen one.
How could you do this to me?
I'll just stay up here.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
They're in the fucking snow.
They can climb up?
Who taught you kids how to climb?
Okay, we got, oh my, okay, Nudo's gone.
Nudo's gone.
Guys, don't worry, they're not burning to death, guys.
It's just all make-believe.
It's all make-believe they're not actually burning to death.
They'll be fine.
The kids don't actually die.
The final wave is coming.
Where the fuck is the final wave?
It's just pretend, chat.
It's just pretend.
Alright.
How can we find you?
I don't even know.
I don't even know how people are going to find my session.
But that's...
This is why I'm the host.
I'll always be number one.
Jimmy!
Any upgrades?
There's still cop...
Who's still alive?
I killed everybody.
I mean, like...
I pretend killed everybody.
Oh.
Oh, they're up there.
Alright.
I think it would be a lot easier if I joined somebody's
party.
But like...
Oh.
Oh my god, you were in the fucking snow this entire time.
Can't believe it.
I can't believe it.
I can't even see him.
My magic wand won't let me see.
Pew, pew, pew.
I need to get him out of the invisibility and then use...
He fucking full healed?
God, these guys are the worst.
These guys are actually the worst.
They can full heal if they hit us.
No, no, don't let him.
Don't let him life steal.
He's 1 HP.
Nice.
Okay.
No, no, I messed it up.
Wee!
How do I mess that up twice?
All right.
Yay!
We did it!
Jimmy, I did it, Jimmy!
Mon flames leave fire patches that last four seconds and
deals three damage.
Oh, wait, I feel like the Molot... Okay, I feel like you
should get napalm.
I think that would be really good.
I don't want to waste my money yet.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go dragons.
Entering Main Street.
Oh hey guys.
Find Stan and smash his army.
And then kick him in the boughs if you can.
Here!
Your army won't help you, Cartman!
You're gonna die today!
I said you're gonna die today!
Yeah, yeah, you're gonna die!
What the fuck?
Bro what?
That's okay, it's just a scratch.
The new kid's dead!
Yeah!
no they're not they're only mostly dead i can yeah just a
little concussion oh yeah your axe gave them um dysentery
dysentery only does 99 that's not fair hey i don't make the
rules actually i kind of do yeah yeah it's okay i'm just
bleeding a little bit i'm out of my head to collect files of
a mysterious gooey stuff and then use We wrote the Book of
Laws.
This isn't fair, butters.
You have to figure something out so I can beat Stan.
Well, if there is an official anything you can do, I can do
two claws in the rulebook.
So technically, we wrote the Book of Laws.
Oh, good.
Do that, new kid.
Finish the quest.
Get powered up.
And stop embarrassing me.
I cast the spell.
Your health is back to 100.
Get the fuck off.
God, I have to do everything around here.
I did it.
My HP is 100 again.
Yay!
Dun, dun, dun.
Don't scare the new fellas.
Be nice to them.
Stay off the streets.
Oh, I guess, like, I have to go here.
We're gonna go this way.
What the fuck?
Remember that Stan has that bullshit axe now.
Touch the ground and you die.
It's like lava.
Oh.
Oh, he can use his axe to, like, kill me.
Really?
What happens if I...
Oh, yeah.
Do I get dysentery again?
It's okay, he only did 99% damage.
Okay, we need to get these guys.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Oh, am I stuck?
Am I stuck here?
Okay, there you go.
It's alright.
I can just stay down here.
Oh, I got some stuff here, too.
Stay off the streets.
Can I just bone rush this?
I don't level up or anything.
The best I get is like...
I think the best I get is like, uh, toilet paper.
Okay, I need to fucking...
I need to fucking heal myself, though.
It's alright!
There's fire!
I dropped!
Oh, it's not okay!
It's not okay!
It was not okay.
JK.
Okay, I grabbed snacks right here.
I'll heal right underneath you.
You can't do anything about it.
Yeah, I'm okay.
Can't do anything to me Alright, nice I guess I'm done
playing Grabbing some toilet paper Oh my god She's pretend
dead, don't worry They're all pretend dead chat Shit, the
next roof is too high And that catapult has a lock on it
We'll have to fight to move forward Alright, we need to grab
some more toilet paper Stay off the street I think we just
have to move forward So we'll be fine Oh, okay, that's my
fire to get into my fire.
Poo, poo, poo, poo.
Can I unlock it yet?
No!
Not the dysentery!
Where am I?
Okay, we're fine.
Please.
Please not the dysentery.
Alright, toilet paper.
It's the currency.
Okay, can I pick this lock?
Wee!
Great, keep moving across the rooftops.
Alright, we gotta get across.
I think he'll stand on Marsh Walker.
Alright, let's see.
I just beat that shit up.
Oh, no, there's a platform right here.
Friends!
Where did my friends go?
How many tunnels are in this driveway?
Where did all my dragoons go?
Friends!
Guys, I swear I have friends.
Guys, I swear.
I swear.
swear to god they'll show up soon they'll show up god the
servers have been so unstable chat wait oh i need toilet
paper here toilet paper all right here we go they broke the
catapult how do we get across now well actually i think that
there was a trebuchet actually i think you should shut the
up fighters we need something stretchy and rubbery to make a
new sling get looking new kid what the look where the Oh,
rubber bends!
Okay, we gotta grab some rubber bends.
Is there, like, rubber bends behind?
Okay, rubber bends over there.
I'm gonna go back fully first before I...
Oh, I should have upgraded stamina.
I did not realize how much stamina matters until now.
Oh, shit.
There's actual people down there.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Pew, pew.
That's right.
burn holy shit this fucking napalm shit is so op yes new kid
that's perfect it's actually so strong like what the fuck it
does so much damage no wonder it's legendary oh i wish i
could like buy the palace forever i was thinking for the
super chat thank you thank you okay i'm gonna fucking speed
run over to the next rubber band.
Oh, I can't.
Deliver the... What?
No, the rubber bands!
Wait a minute.
I thought it were rubber bands.
What do you mean?
I'm gonna put the rubber band in.
The very real rubber band.
Nice No Come down and fight bear
Holy shit Okay, I'm gonna use the bubble so I can No, please
Someone Someone please Mimi please, where are you?
Mimi Mimi Ria Okay, we need to get rid of this firework Okay
Okay.
We got rid of one of them.
Oh, we have- it's more than one rubber- rubber band?
Okay.
I'm gonna head over.
I'm heading over to the other rubber band right now.
Wait, is she okay?
She's okay.
She'll be fine.
She'll be so fine.
Oh, God.
Nice.
More toilet paper.
I need a grab.
A chest open!
Driving the dark matter, taking this.
Guys, it's just to protect the catapult, okay?
It's a...
It's to make balloon animals!
Chat, it's a balloon animal!
It's what clowns use to make balloon animals!
That's what it is!
That's why it's so stretchy and long.
Whoa!
Look how long it...
It makes really big balloon out of...
They can make a dog!
Alright, we're gonna grab, get rid of...
I'm just gonna fucking bone rush it.
It's okay, I have my dragoons here to distract them.
It's all right.
I don't need to save them.
They're independent.
They're strong independent goons.
Here we go.
Where the fuck is the last rubber band?
The last balloon animal.
There it is.
That should be enough to repair.
Bullshit.
Oh, no.
Oh, it's just noodle arms.
That's fine.
A bullshit card was played.
Your weapons are all floppy now.
It's okay.
I can just run.
Phew.
I'm just gonna run.
It's alright.
We're fine.
Ignore everybody!
We have so much toilet paper!
We don't need the money!
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Oh god, the hockey player is still here.
Oh!
Get off me!
Bruh!
Taking out their feet.
I did it!
Goodbye, dragons!
I'll always remember you.
Don't worry, I'll remember everything you've done for me,
Dragons.
I did not leave you.
I...
I'll always remember your heart...
Oh!
Dragons!
Come back!
Remember me!
Dragons!
Take the catapult!
Dragoons, take the catapult!
Dragoons!
I told you I remember you, just take the catapult!
Where are they?
Please, I'm on my knees begging.
Just take the catapult, Mimi!
Not the dysentery!
There's a catapult right there!
Oh my god!
Riz, Riz, you have Crandon too!
But you're not ginger, so like you're not as good as me.
Oh my god.
There we go.
See, look at that.
Look at that, guys.
See, I always remember my goons.
Chat.
I always remember them.
Never forget.
Never forget what they do.
Did
Guys I guys I told you never leave a goon behind Never leave
a goon behind chat Oh my god, am I burning people or they
burning people?
I would never I would never do something that fucked up
Okay, we're gonna have to get rid of these guys All right,
nice.
I use the shield just in time Come on Why are you guys so
fucking tanky?
My shield should go...
You're literally standing on napalm!
There we go, we're good.
We're good.
I defeat...
Oh, God, not the hockey players.
It's okay.
They can't take high ground.
There you go.
They don't know how to climb.
He knows how to climb.
But what if he doesn't know how to climb this platform,
though?
It's okay.
He doesn't know how to climb this platform.
one.
Here we go.
That's right.
See, I told you.
You can't jump down and find Jimmy.
Jimmy?
Where the fuck is Jimmy?
Jimmy's over here.
Jimmy!
That's not Jimmy.
Oh, Jimmy's over here.
There's also chests.
Nice.
More dark matter.
Is that another chest over there?
No, that's just a dead guy.
Pretend dead.
That's just a guy being pretend dead.
All right, we move on.
Hello,
Jimmy.
All right, let's see.
They're all coming from behind with your dagger.
Okay, we're going to reshuffle.
These cards suck.
Oh, when using Pissed Off Heal 40.
I feel like I haven't really used the Pissed Off abilities.
So...
All right, I actually forgot which one was Pissed Off.
hire one use bullshit wait how do i use pissed off do i
automatically use my pissed off button enjoy these upgrades
new kid you burned him okay miss chest that's all right
we're just gonna move on baby get over here wait for
everyone to upgrade oh yeah mimi has to upgrade oh the q and
me oh
That's the pissed off stuff.
That's just mana.
That makes so much more sense now.
I have been using them.
I was just testing you guys.
I knew all around.
I just wanted...
I was just testing all of you.
Alright.
okay shield all right i just gotta just gotta keep my beam
up god this attack is so strong i think i'm gonna fucking be
a wand user i'm gonna be a filthy magic user all right now
seven more enemies kick all their asses get over here child
get over here you're not going to first grade it's hot
you're gonna be held back in kindergarten jimmy Oh, Jimmy.
Get over here.
Oh, I cannot use during combat.
God damn it.
Guys, we need to kill five more.
Here we go.
Yay.
All right.
They're all in my fire, so that's good.
We're taking all the damage.
Last guy.
Don't get one guy.
Wait.
Where's the last guy?
Wait a minute.
It's all the way over here?
over here is he stuck what is he doing kid you can't hide
from you can't hide from me you die here all right nice
upgrade here's what fate has in store the bubble burns
enemies inside oh my god oh i cannot upgrade it i'm too weak
see him hey nice all right let's go no child left behind
exactly we're about to kick his ass all right that's a
little better isn't it i moved some snow didn't i we did not
read that truck who was in winter time a dumb stupid fucking
bitch like me that's who pushing where yeah she's so
relatable she's true just like me for real for real So
fucking true.
Just run!
They didn't even wait for the trial.
Who cares?
Oh, just keep running!
Player one?
The wolves say you gotta finish coming.
Okay, guys, we have to actually attack guys.
Apparently we actually have to fight.
We can't just run.
God damn it.
We actually have to kill everybody.
All right, here we go.
Wait, what's this?
Oh no, we need a cannonball?
Does Cartman actually fight or he's just there being a
badass?
Oh fuck.
Can't believe it.
Not my king.
A king does not fight.
A king makes other fight and die for you.
Right dragoons?
Alright, you guys will fight for me.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
Don't worry, we're gonna beat up the 6th grader.
That's alright.
You're not gonna see any girl.
Puberty is gonna be a fucking miserable time for you.
Alright, yay!
Did we kill everybody?
Where?
There's still enemies, new kid.
You gotta beat that guy.
That one kid over there that's just standing there?
Bro!
He's not even oh, he's catapult already is that wait what?
I looked at him and then he pretend died Getting the
catapult we need to get over this.
He actually pretend that he's like oh no it's Doki.
Oh no We got him.
We got him.
We got a tap out Okay, I'm running.
No Get the out of here.
Where do we have to go?
Jimmy!
Is it here?
Is he at the theater?
Where the fuck is he?
Find him near City Hall.
Is this City Hall?
Where the fuck are they?
Oh, there's like chests, though.
I should actually grab some toilet paper.
I do not have a lot of money.
Wait, is that...
The golf kids!
A three-card spread.
Okay, replenish all zero.
Sacrifice chain lightning to max the level of all your other
upgrades.
No way.
I'll take the dark matter.
Cool.
Yeah, there's no way I'm getting rid of the chain lightning.
That chain lightning is actually so fucking good.
It's been like...
It's been like clutching it for me.
Because I can be like extra lazy.
And I love being extra lazy.
Where the fuck do we go?
get out of here using a filthy bow pew damn stuff unlimited
power no drink bullshit oh yeah we're nerping your melee
guys some of ours had to go take a lead they played a phone
weapon card new kid your close friends attacks do minus
damage it's me the real new kid Mimi Mimi get over here I'm
need you.
I have real dragoon number three.
Real dragoon number three.
How long does it take?
That res me?
Alright.
I need to use shield.
Nice.
Just gonna.
You know I'm gonna put a totem pole right inside here.
It should be five.
They burn inside my bubble anyway.
So I get my pissed off rage at the same time So I never lose
my piss off because they're always in my bubble.
We need more viruses.
Come on, Mark Blackard.
What the fuck?
Oh, no.
Sixth graders.
Did you just hit me?
Get out.
Sixth graders, please.
I'm so sorry.
Please.
I'm so scared.
All right.
They have a lot of unresolved issues because they get
bullied by the seventh graders.
Here I come.
All right, nice.
All right.
I'm gonna go inside.
Oh, holy fuck.
God, that hurt.
I'm always...
That's the secret.
I'm always pissed off.
Alright.
There's still, like, the...
Oh, no.
The girls.
It's the girls.
I'm so scared.
You think they'll like me late after this?
Alright.
Nice.
That should be all of them.
Right?
I kill everybody?
Ready for the big fight?
You'll want an upgrade.
great time.
Bubble shield is 40% bigger?
Alright, we're getting that.
It's 50% bigger now.
Nice.
Alright, I'm ready for the battle.
Mimi, get over here!
Wait, Mimi, where are you?
Oh, it's... They went to the Goff kids.
Alright.
You gotta upgrade for this, and then we're gonna kill Stan
Marsh.
We're making up some rules oh
my god we got cred wait you paid 50 dollars too oh my god
we're both stupid we pre-ordered before reading the reviews
that's us we're also in the grid yay my marsh walker powers
so i'm just gonna have my friend kenny kick your ass kenny
all right you kid take out princess kenny don't let her kid
kiss you or you're totally gonna be pussy women.
But you scab.
What the fuck?
Oh shit.
Princess Kinney is working with Stan.
No!
That charming son of a bitch is gonna try and stop us with
her big titties and her salty kisses.
She's using her anime powers!
Oh my god!
Somebody stop her!
She's too kawaii!
Oh my god!
Dragon number three, you were in love with Kenny?
I mean, who is it, though?
Look at her.
Your enemy back is up.
Holy fuck.
I bought him.
Got a fucking simp, man.
Where is it?
No, they fell out.
Baby, no!
Oh my god, what?
What is this?
Holy shit.
All right.
She can fly.
How the fuck the stats get Kenny?
That's my OG.
Alright, we gotta heal.
It's okay.
I have bubble powers.
He's in the bubble, so he's gonna take damage.
This is so much easier than the fucking Kyle fight.
Alright.
I'm good.
I'm heals.
my god not the bomb not the bomb not the bomb player two are
you tired or did you just get bugged up all right here we go
we're good we're good we're good he's one hit princess
kenny's one hit shoot him don't revive me me just kill him
me me down kenny he made my kami oh she that's hooking right
kenny be like this damn it we did it see look you're okay
you're okay maybe my oh my god you killed maoshi that chest
over there that is grab that chest
i'm gonna double check if we're missing anything all right
we should be good lead through the gate we're gonna go
through we're gonna kill you stan
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, it's here?
Oh, it's over here.
Alright.
Yeah!
We did it!
Look at that.
Most damage given.
I got defeat 10 shield barriers.
Oh my god, we got the Tesla coil.
Wherever I go.
Tesla's always there we've
defeated the princess but stan still needs an ass kicking
good job new kid princess kitty toyed wait it's not oh okay
i was gonna say now load out and get back out there all
right school is closed and i am so bored i can sense a
growing darkness deep within your soul join me and we can
pierce the veil between the worlds come find me in the fact
kids backyard What the fuck?
What is that?
What the fuck?
Where is she?
Where's the god kid?
We need to pierce the veil.
Hey, need a weapon?
Can I unlock anything?
No, I haven't.
Oh, I got the whooppy cushion.
Uh...
Release a drifting void that's sucks enemies in and I feel
like the heals and the fucking bubble is just way too good
where is he where the fuck is the goth kit oh there she is
okay I'm gonna talk to mr.
hanky first uh I am going to do sprinting this okay that
should be good wait don't I have missing what there's deals
I pre-ordered what do you mean wait there's more okay I need
a okay excuse me what do you mean that's DLC I literally
have the deluxe version
I have the deluxe version version wait okay oh it's free
guys it's a free dlc chat it's a free dlc okay all right at
least that's free thank god i was like there's no way i
literally bought the deluxe version what the you mean like i
need to have more dlc how do i have need more dlc A zombie,
thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Behold, the land of Zaron.
Wait, there's only three chapters?
Oh!
You know what, fuck it, let's just play all of it.
It's just three more chapters.
I mean, we're so good at this game.
Now I understand.
Now I understand why people were like, I can't believe it.
We can bypass three chapters, more chapters.
All right, guys, it's still open.
The session is still open, guys.
Time to set a battle.
You know what?
Okay, kick off.
Okay, you know what?
I'm gonna...
I don't need to be number one.
I don't need to be number one, chat.
I am...
I know I'm number one in my heart.
know.
I know
I...
Okay, let's see.
Chapter 3.
I know I'm number one in my heart.
Okay.
That's fine.
What is the avoid spoilers off?
Okay, join.
There has to be one game out there.
That's on chapter 3.
Hey, player two, try not to slow us down.
Where are we?
What is this stage?
Okay, never mind.
I'm leaving.
Sorry, I don't understand.
Somewhere in chapter three.
I thought I joined in the middle of...
All right, never mind.
Never mind.
I'll be number one.
never mind i guess i'll be number one let's go all right i'm
gonna use the bathroom real quick i'll be back everybody
we're gonna finish all the chapters i'll be right back
all right i'm back all right guys guys now i understand how
this works now i now i figured it out all right got it mike
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you can sell
even the mightiest warriors with only
win the combat which is a new rule that we've all Wait,
what?
Oh, okay, I have to...
Oh, okay, I have to pass...
Well, I thought I already passed the test of strength.
What do you mean?
I have to do it again?
We already know I'm fucking strong.
Remember, these are designated OP moves that you can only
use for a limited time.
Choose carefully.
I missed my...
You're going to actually face us this time, Marshwalker?
There's no way you'll be able to get through the test of
strength.
Oh, shit!
The napalm!
Nice.
We still have the napalm.
strong all right moon jump oh i just realized i never used
my fucking bullshit um become huge and body slam fools or do
areas damage oh wait that's so good time to match you up
folks i forgot to use my bullshit cards gigantism awesome
and some cards to upgrade our magic you think you can stop
us with that not a chance you aren't ready for this march
giants launched halflings I still have so many cards.
It's not even hard mode anymore.
They still have four cards.
Carmen, why aren't you making new rules to put us in there?
This is still four cards.
You'll be at his power level, or at least immune to
dysentery.
Alright, I need...
Okay guys, I need new kids to move over.
Well, I guess everyone's here looking for supplies.
I just wanted to know if everybody had the same amount of
cards if I put normal mode now I know it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what fucking mode I'm on they'll always have
more cards than me go talk to his uncle Jimbo he can tell
you what to do okay uncle Jimbo I'm just gonna grab these
fucking oh I'm gonna miss this app though what's next no
more ground flaxseed i gotta mill it myself what the is
ground flaxseeds what the is that hey guys please you gotta
help us you're the only store still open we're so hungry we
need food do you have any food settle down everyone one at a
time you're all acting crazy it's a snowstorm it's not the
apocalypse the end is now everyone it's the It's so weird
seeing them have noses.
It's so weird.
Wait, your turn.
Oh, you're what a stance, friends.
Are you here about that quest I gave him?
Tell you what.
It's a gun store.
What do you mean with guns?
America.
Give you whatever you want.
That butter's creamy goose stuff seems to be popular.
Go get some of that and bring it back.
It's so weird that they have fucking noses.
Like, I understand it's 3D, but it's still, it's just, it's
not right.
It's not right.
It's right.
That's me!
I have the funny hat!
Okay, I need to fucking get pissed off right now.
All right, get over here.
I'm gonna burn you.
It's not the same.
It's not like the electricity.
But it's okay.
I have which is napalm nice okay nice I have more shield
that's right unlimited shield unlimited shield if I'm always
angry wait I can just literally skip all these people
goodbye
goodbye it's speed run time oh my god I'm blinded by what
realize why now I realize why I need I can't just now I
realize why I can't just carry everything oh my god what the
fuck is hitting me okay yeah yeah don't worry guys protect
the leader protect number one the real new kid protect me oh
oh Please.
All right.
Nice be fine.
We're fine.
Oh shit.
Who keeps hitting me?
Your children.
It should be like a fucking Hulk.
Protect the ghoul.
Yep, that kid's definitely got an advantage.
It's okay.
It's just a flesh wound.
Oh, those are not my teammates.
That's okay.
Body blocked I've got it.
It's all right.
It doesn't hurt me That's creamy as I'll get out.
Nice work kid.
Yeah, here's the next thing.
Yes, but he's a tiny your child My power level should be
bigger I should have a higher power level there are actual
kids all right here we go we're gonna fucking heal up before
we go in grab barrel of nfts what bro not the nfts that's
still fucking relevant i thought nfts are dead what was it
the fucking um board ape shit did you guys hear like uh who
was it there was a celebrity that Ape and lost like $200,000
or some shit.
Oh my god.
I need people.
I need people here right now.
There's like...
Oh, is it Kevin Hart?
Yeah.
Apparently Kevin Hart lost like $200k.
He like so... Oh, not $200, like $140,000 because he bought
an NFT for...
He bought an NFT for like 200k and then sold it for like 60k
or something.
Like sold his board A for 60k.
Because like nobody cares about NFTs anymore.
Or like nobody in NA cares about NFTs anymore because the
fucking thing crashed.
Poor like poor like Seth Green if he at Seth Green and the
fucking cartoon that he wanted to make but he couldn't
because a hacker stole his nft oh god oh god oh i'm so angry
i'm so angry no i'm sure someone will pick you up anytime
now no number two my real dragon res me my very real dragon
it's okay i'm gonna get rest i know you can i know your
program to rest It's nice.
Okay.
We're good.
We got the healers too.
Hey.
Oh, I'm trying my best to speed run.
It's okay.
We're okay.
We can outrun this.
But yeah, the reason why like, Jesus Christ.
Oh, no.
No.
I can't, I'll run this.
Oh, the tiny kid is too strong.
All right, we're good.
We're okay.
Where the fuck is the fireworks guy?
Who the fuck?
How did he fucking, like, slump me?
Oh, God.
That is, like, a fucking...
That's, like, a word from the past.
Okay.
Okay, Harry, we're good.
We're good.
We don't have to worry about the...
But yeah, for those who don't know, Seth Green bought...
Oh, God.
Not these guys.
Seth Green fucking tried to make an NFT animated.
Half animated, half like...
Oh, come on.
Get the fuck away from me.
Okay.
Half animated, half live action show about NFTs.
And then the main character...
is one of his nfts and then his nft account got hacked and
then they blackmailed him because they knew he was making a
show and so he couldn't get his nft back to wait no he paid
like triple double the price again to have his board eight
back so he could have his show you know what a chin pokemon
is me neither but people will pay good toilet paper for oh i
got chin pokemon
No, I saw the trailer for that show and it's fucking
terrible.
It's so bad.
It's actually so fucking bad.
Don't worry.
It's okay.
They don't know I'm here.
They don't know I'm a child.
Alright, here we go.
I mean, yeah, the board aid fucking...
Oh, guys, did you hear about the fucking board aid
convention that end up making people fucking half?
Like, blind?
the board ape event, that shit was crazy!
That shit was actually fucking insane because they used like
some, like, light or whatever.
Okay, so board ape had, like, a fucking event and they used,
like, like, some black light or whatever to, like, make it
cool, but then they inadvertently bought, like, the most
expensive black light that was used to kill, like...
Radiation or whatever.
They use UV lights.
UV lights and stuff.
No, wasn't it, like, expensive UV lights that ended up
being, like, oh, they cheaped out on UV lights?
Yeah.
Yeah, and then they, like, they bought, like, industrial UV
lights that ended up, like, fucking, causing blindness.
That was actually so fucked up.
the sixth graders oh no not the sixth grade it was supposed
to be used to disinfect things but they didn't using it for
like a a fucking party like an actual dance event which was
like absolutely insane that that was a thing no yeah it was
used for a fucking concert it literally like caught
blindness the next day like that's actually insane all right
here you real dragon res me very real dragon where's number
four well is number four stuck okay there you are all right
it's okay my very real dragoons are helping me did you just
hit me a very real dragoons res me Don't worry, Nino.
It's actually crazy.
I know, like, the market in NA has actually crashed.
But I don't know if, like, other areas, if it's still, like,
survive.
If it's still surviving.
Oh, yeah, and skin burns, too.
That is actually insane.
It's actually insane that that's real.
That actually happened.
Oh, no.
Not my chimp Pokemon.
Chimp Pokemon!
You scratch my back, I'll scratch yours.
Yeah.
And for your reward, you could use my porta potty anytime
you want.
What the fuck am I gonna use the porta potty for?
Oh, Mr. Hanky?
Oh, uh, that wasn't really what I imagined out of that test.
Alright.
Mr. Hanky?
Oh!
No!
I feel violated there.
What the fuck?
What the fuck happened?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
What the fuck happened?
There got venom?
Oh my god.
It's like got venom there.
I guess I'm immune to dysentery now.
Oh, you're getting pretty desperate.
Better get you an upgrade.
does more okay the wand drops a Molotov that deals okay I
feel like I just use my wand I'm just gonna get the Molotov
nice uh wrap though thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you signal pyres using the eternal flame your test
begin are you going to replay the other South Park RPGs I
won't play Fractured but hold one day but i'm not sure when
i'm just trying to figure out like okay so like if i should
stream that on youtube i played i hundred percent stink of
truth and i know i know the shit that's in there so i'm just
like i don't know what the fuck lighting your body on fire
well that's one way to do it i guess yeah that's one using
your body as a human torch that's pretty stupid but i like
works it works just a little flat fire you know the fire
doesn't even hurt you praise Christ quick new kid use your
hot body to light the torches I'm heading over don't worry
oh they can't get me I have the shield my real dragons
protect the snow who would have thought who would have
thought if you go into the if you go into the snow you you
just stop burning who would have thought that was that could
happen did i freeze to death you can't keep running into
arrows and stay alive i'm trying guys you don't just run
into like 20 people and expect to live guys a little pro tip
for a little pro tip don't just run into everything
expecting you to live all right oh god i really need heals
right now no these guys suck fucking what is the power skill
nerf him nerf him nerf this man oh god i'm not angry enough
i need to be angrier okay i need to be angrier oh my god i
need a shield too oh please be angry be angry new kid all
right all right i think we're angry enough now we have to be
angry what the fuck is freezing me oh it's the snow it's the
snow that's still making me angry Let's change this.
Dems!
Dems have balanced this game!
Oh my god.
Okay, I need to get rid of...
I need to get rid of the fucking fireworks if I want to head
anywhere.
Alright, we should be good.
We should be good now.
Where do we go?
Okay, I'm gonna burn myself here.
Like, how do I get up top?
that's what I do no fuck I cooled myself down okay no
stamina again which way do I go I'm so confused oh top here
you climb climb no oh come on come on where where's the
thing why give me
No.
Alright.
Okay.
Apparently there was a ledge.
Where am I?
Oh hey there's Jimmy right here.
I need Jimmy right here.
Alright let's just heal.
I'm gonna stay over here and heal a little bit.
Let's just...
Let's just chill down.
Chill a little bit here.
Alright.
We're gonna figure this out.
I'm not that stupid.
There's a ledge.
Okay, there's a ledge right here.
We can climb this ledge.
Maybe you'll learn something from the more experienced new
kids.
Where, what is that supposed to mean?
Cartman.
What is that supposed to mean, Cartman?
I'm not on fire again?
Where do I climb?
Mr. Man!
Where do I do?
What do I do?
I'm still burning.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, I burned.
Wait, this counts!
Oh, God.
Yes!
Oh, I hit... No!
What?!
I mean, it still doesn't count!
Okay.
Ah!
Ow!
All right What do you mean it climbed on top of it?
All right Okay, we gotta figure this out guys We gotta
figure this out My speed run Guys, what about my speed run?
Okay This is it I can climb up Where do I go?
All right We got another one We got another barrow one
closer keep going.
I'm almost there Please no Oh, I got I'm getting bullshit so
hard.
This is it your buddy is getting jockeied.
I'm ready to bullshit
Doki slam All right, nice.
We got it Doki is ready to slam Okay, we need to like get
more of the fire though.
All right, nice, all right.
Get away, get away.
Doki is slamming.
I just need to get there faster.
Okay, got another one.
All right.
No, it's literally right there!
Don't let me die!
You got another beacon, nice.
Yes!
Okay, we're gonna heal right here though.
All right, nice.
It's okay.
My entire team can kill everybody else.
We have two more.
All right, we gotta go this way.
Don't worry, the speedrun is still there.
The speedrun is still possible.
Woo!
Okay, we gotta get rid of this guy, though.
The fucking ice shit is actually pissing me off.
Stokey angry now get out get out women shielded women get
out this is a boy's only boy's only tree house okay nice
okay where the fuck do I go oh god no my fire all right nice
I'll get rid of these two nice Let's get her getting
goodies.
And then we're gonna press this.
And then catapult us above.
And then...
Thank Christ.
Oh god, thank god.
Is it that time for me too?
Alright.
Burn.
Burn children.
A pretend burn.
Oh no, sixth graders.
Sixth graders!
Oh!
Oh my god.
the reason why like all these cartoon shows they never like
get they never get like like they never age up or go to a
next grade is because they want to always have continuity so
that people can what's the word when syndication oh yeah
yeah so they can always run reruns all the time that's the
only reason why people never grow up it's actually the test
has been completed You've done well head to the chamber of
great is actually fucked up
The network just wants to be able to run reruns all the
time.
It's also why like a lot of characters don't go through
character development Because if they go through character
development running reruns don't make sense
And I watched it
And I watched it happen.
Alright, let's see.
Common, uncommon.
I'm gonna reshuffle.
I need something that has to do with the wand.
I don't like the dagger.
Or the bubble.
Oh, the bubble is so good.
Yeah.
I've had my eye on that one myself.
Yeah, this one's really good.
See you.
Did you know dragons don't eat paladins?
Apparently they taste lawful.
Ha!
Okay, that one was good, Jimmy.
Will ever have more than one friend?
Okay, we gotta go downstairs.
Become an honorary marsh.
Wait, I became an honorary marshwalker?
Oh, it's this way.
There we go.
Stan's at the playground.
Let's take a shortcut through the theater.
Just run!
Oh, I'm stuck.
Go, my faithful warrior!
Speed run!
We don't need toilet paper!
Just go, go, go, go!
Just run.
Okay, we need to heal though.
We can stay here and heal a little bit.
That's okay.
Wait, if you just run, Mr. Man!
Just one of us has to get there!
Oh, God.
Okay, never mind.
I have to get back.
pissed off.
I have to be angie.
Alright.
No!
The key!
Not the level 3 elf's lock!
Okay.
Let's get rid of.
Let's get rid of the fireworks, people.
This is how war is our one.
Alright.
Nice.
That's right.
Get into my bubba.
Oh, yeah?
We got supersized.
Kid Cannon.
So now we get to throw our angriest little kids at you.
Somehow it's still legal.
It's legal if it's all the kids.
Okay, it's legal if only the kids are doing it, okay?
That's why it's legal.
Oh, God.
I need to get the bubble and then heals, too.
The bubbles and heals are so good.
They're so strong.
All right.
Get over here.
I need to do the level three Elven lock.
Oh, where am I?
Okay.
Bubble time.
There's still, like, two more kids left.
I thought it would feel different.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
He has unlimited kids!
When you get rid of the fireworks, they have too many kids.
Alright, nice.
Last child.
Fun and fodder.
Let's go.
Alright.
Almost there, new kid.
We're so close to kicking Stan's ass.
That...
No, that's not toilet paper.
Oh, any cheese.
What the fuck is this?
What trailer is this?
This is an Easter egg?
The greatest Canadian duo of all time is back.
Oh my god.
I'm watching it backwards.
This is Philip.
Will you away.
fly the two.
Uh, fast!
Oh, I could have watched it in the back I didn't realize no
I could have watched it here No my movie I didn't understand
Oh my god, you're ruining my movie experience Okay
It moved way too fast.
Alright, nice.
I barely can see who's in front of me.
With how many people are dying.
Ah, there's a fire!
2!
I knew it.
I knew that was what's coming out.
We all know Candace not real.
Because I'm not real.
just anatomy girl people invented Canada for vtubers that's
why all that's why all vtubers are that's why that's why a
lot of english-speaking vtubers are from Canada it's not
real we just say Canada as like the made-up country it makes
sense doesn't it it all makes sense now we say Canada
because we were like oh where you're from we're Canada bro
what the fuck child shit is a bad word not in my Christian
South Park stream it's all a simulation we're still alive
we're still alive what child oh they're over here they're
over here beat up these children nope Oh no!
There we go.
That's fine.
I just don't have to move.
I just right click.
Easiest game of my life.
Right click to win.
Right your way to the rest of downtown.
All right.
We just gotta run.
Don't look back.
Fake new kid.
Just keep running.
We're gonna need to pass through the ice to get to Stan.
Find a cannon bob.
Careful fellas.
Stan's got cannons too.
The cannonball!
Wait, where is the cannonball?
Dude, your weapons can't break this!
Use the cannons!
Where the fuck?
Where the fuck is the cannonball?
Oh, it's over here!
I found one!
I got one!
Break it!
Whoa, nice shot!
Just a few more and you're in!
One more hit and that barrier is going down!
Okay, we need one more.
Fake new kid!
Not the main character new kid!
Where's the other cannonball?
Wait, where is the other cannonball?
Oh, it's on me.
See, I got it.
I got it, but I can't jump because it's realism.
Because when you're a child, you can't jump and you have a
cannonball because it's not safe.
Oh, wait, here you got the other one.
Jimmy!
You have.
Let's get you an upgrade.
Okay, uncommon.
Oh, look at it's 20%.
Yes.
Do I have enough upgrade?
I do.
Okay.
This is the OP one.
Ah, yes.
A fine upgrade.
all right nice welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome
all right let's go
oh no 16 damage 16 damage what the hell yeah what the hell
the test of strength your 10 plus act is largely ineffective
now wait a minute the new kid has a secret power too so then
i'm not super op anymore oh does that mean cartman wins but
not exactly why'd you just use the class 10 combat base that
you built you have a dragon for christ's sake oh he has a
dragon okay new kids prepare to die how the fuck are we
gonna hit stan all the way up there yeah how the fuck does
he get a dragon there's a cannon put me in boss wait i'm
boss children put me in i'm boss wait where the fuck is the
other cannon oh my god there's more We're gonna do it.
We're going down, dude.
I got the other cannon.
Jumping into the deep snow to put out those slings, buddy.
It's okay.
But how do I get the cannonball up top?
Oh, there is.
There's a wrap.
The only way to get out of your defenses is with the cannon.
Look around for some cannonballs.
But how do I put it in?
Yeah, let him fucking have it.
How did you...
You might have completed the test of strength.
How did you get up there?
How does Mr. Men do it?
Number two!
I have a catapult right here!
What do I do?
How did you get up?
I'm gonna watch you.
How did you do it?
You're no match for me, new kid.
Oh, there's a wrap!
There's a wrap!
I figured it out, guys.
There was a wrap.
Guys, we did it.
God, we're so smart.
We're so fucking smart.
Who would have thought there was a ramp all along?
It was right here
I was a little bit directionally challenged Get over here,
Stan.
I completed the quest.
I used the dark matter, but you're not new Maybe I wasn't
using enough.
Oh God, no Oh, no, please get that thing away from me.
Okay, that thing kind of hurts.
Get that thing away.
No, get away from me!
You can't hide from my axe.
Oh, God.
It's okay.
There's so much fire going on.
Oh, God, to be angry.
I have to be angry.
Get in my bubble.
Get in the flames.
Oh, my God.
You I where are you he's just whacking me where is he okay.
Okay, I need to get the bubble in Yeah That's right As
closer you get to me the more damage you're gonna get You
won't beat me.
I won't March Walker Clarence.
Oh Everyone's going crazy fighting each other for toilet
paper, but I've been finding these treasure chests filled
with it all over the place People are just leaving them in
hidden but easily findable locations Can you believe that?
I also beat up stotch and took his toilet paper, too, but
we're gonna be rich dad Dad not now.
I have to defeat my enemies enemies.
Well, wait So if you lose do they get to take our toilet
paper?
I guess yeah, those are the rules.
Oh shit No, they can't have our toilet paper.
Wait, but he's an adult Join in the middle of a class 10
base siege.
Well, uh, you know what sure what what?
Right.
I'm cutting you down.
Oh my god.
Oh my god Oh my god!
He fucked up my- Oh my god!
I just- Oh!
Where am I?
I turned into a PNG because of Randy!
I turned into a PNG because of Randy.
Like, what the fuck?
That's fucked up, man.
Randy, that's fucked up.
Okay Okay, how did he die?
He almost had you.
Oh my god Bro Where the fuck?
Okay, he's one hit guys.
Let me kill still.
Let me kill.
Yeah, I killed my son.
He's a warrior Dad Please do whatever you want to stand
don't hurt the toilet paper.
I was gonna be rich ha ha ha ha i can't believe i can't
pause in an online game thank you guys for not letting me
die guys i can't believe it i can't i still managed to pause
an online game let's go
look at us go we're so good no problem
I play a game at Honorary's Marsh Walker.
Let's go.
Pause the internet.
Pause!
Why couldn't you just play by the same rules as everyone
else?
Because my version of the rules actually work.
The way you guys do it, it doesn't even make any sense.
You don't even know what power-ups go with what abilities.
And that's why you turned into a total dick?
Oh, I'm a dick because I stood up for what I believe in.
Shouldn't be awarded every level.
It's confusing.
Well, we beat you, Stan.
Wait, what?
But that makes sense.
Yeah, so can you please stop this witcher spell before more
people get hurt?
What are you talking about?
Yeah, what are you talking about?
Come on, Stan.
We know this snowstorm isn't natural.
Somebody used magic.
Do you really think I would purposely start a storm that's
killing people and shutting down the whole town?
The way you've been acting lately, yes.
Why did you turn against everybody and get all aggro?
I don't know, okay?
He's going through things.
I guess ever since I got that dark matter stuff from...
Yes, Mr. Hanky!
What did you say?
I got this dark matter stuff from my axe.
Mr. Hanky!
From Mr. Hanky?
The Christmas Pooh?
He's the secret villain!
That could be it.
What could it be?
Don't you guys remember?
Mr. Hanky was kicked out of town.
By the entire town.
Yeah, that's why I was like surprised Mr. Hanky's back.
He got phased out.
Oh, come on!
It wasn't you!
No!
Oh, no!
about that episode.
If anyone would want to hurt this town, how could you accept
dark gifts from Mr. Hanky and not tell anyone, Stan?
And this is why I'm scared of playing a second game on
YouTube.
I remember that episode.
I guess we have to find Mr. Hanky and put a stop to him.
By Zaron's balls, we'll find him and destroy his dark
powers.
And then we can stop this horrible winter storm.
And then all the stores can finally open again.
Yeah.
And people stop fighting over toilet paper and get back to
work.
Right.
Yeah.
And we can get back to going to school what right we can all
get back to no no karmic's gonna be the other secret villain
chapter four is gonna be whoa whoa whoa i don't think this
is going to end well ned no what do you want guns for hot
cocoa anyone free delicious hot cocoa everyone's favorite
winter tantric i know you're all tired and hungry and cold
how about something to get you through the net Father Maxie,
would you like some hot cocoa?
Uh, sure.
I guess I can have a little hot cocoa before the world ends.
It's pretty cold.
I'll take some hot cocoa.
I'll have some too.
Does it have dark matter?
Oh, it has dark matter!
We're gonna fight adults?
It's not pretend anymore.
And you'll never have to, Eric.
Sweet.
No.
I sense great dark matter within you.
That's not dark matter.
Oh my god.
Guys, I think this is a medical concern now.
I think.
Oh no.
It's probably buried in like 50 feet of snow.
Guys.
I think this is a medical concern now.
I don't think.
Oh no.
Constructed mechanical monstrosity.
see that fire snowballs for you.
I still feel the shield is really good compared to...
I feel like I'm still going to run shield and heals.
What's this?
Oh, that's it!
I get dizzy swinging that thing.
Okay, that's the level 10.
That's the level 10 battle axe.
Okay.
And then...
Alright, and then press while jumping to... Whoa!
That's fucking crazy.
Alright, dark matter time.
Let's see.
You deal 20% damage?
Fuck yeah.
Oh, I do not have a lot.
Ice skater.
Oh.
Alright.
I don't know about that.
I don't know.
I'm worried about this dark matter thing now.
Not this dark matter.
Alright, let's see.
time all right here we go are you ready wait where's wait no
who's gonna carry me why are they always gone when i need
them the most the true
enemy of south park has been revealed humans and elves must
join forces to defeat mr hanky snow days are great but they
can't last forever it's time to stop this endless winter
Sammy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
TLDR, if you're pooping dark matter, please see a doctor.
If your poop starts talking back to you, there might be
something wrong with your brain.
Huh, no one's here.
Oh, well, choose your cards.
We'll need all the bullshit we can to defeat Mr. Hanky.
Wait, does that mean Mr. Hanky doesn't get bullshit?
Oh, God.
Fucking flashbang out of nowhere.
Oh, wait.
but okay all right pick some cards the wand is but we set
you on fire over time you know what that's a risk I'm gonna
take being on fire for a little bit wouldn't be that bad
right I'm gonna go with the this time I'll actually use this
bullshit oh cool radioactivity he is the bullshit and then
this snow day will finally be over and we can all go back to
skew ha ha Surprise!
The plot twist!
You're gonna have to go through me!
God damn it, Carmen, what are you doing?
I'm finally gonna live the life I've always dreamt of, Cam?
A life with no skin.
Mr. Henke is ruining South Park.
We can't keep living like this.
Don't worry, you won't be living much longer anyways.
Mr. Henke has given me the power of dark magic, and I'm
gonna use it to destroy you guys!
Wait, but then that means he gets like...
I'm totally betraying you now.
Fifteen cards!
He can do the spells.
He can do the bad spells.
What a twist.
Wait, but like who the fuck is in his army?
With me and my dark army in control.
We never have to go to school again.
You should be thanking me.
I fucking knew Karma was onto something.
We have to stop him.
Oh my god.
That's not fair.
You got adults to play pretend with.
This is not pretend anymore.
The adults are going to beat up children!
That's a lawsuit!
Make your way through the backyards.
Oh no.
The Venom Army.
Bro!
What fucking slap from a dog?
What?
Carmen's got them all hopped up on dark matter.
Oh god.
Thank god it's just a kid.
Guys it's okay.
It's just a child.
It's okay.
guys.
Oh, no.
There's no napalm.
This is so much more difficult without napalm now.
This is actually more difficult.
Alright.
We're fine.
Okay.
We got it.
Oh, no.
We got it here.
Is it because I'm also on fire?
That I'm taking... No, it can't be.
No, that can't be it.
Okay, we gotta get rid of the me i got the i got the fucking
barrier they're so tanky we're oh they're so fucking what
the hell why are they so strong what holy they're actually
so strong it's actually crazy okay even if i do like 50 more
damage they do so much okay fine we're gonna say stay here
for now we're gonna heal forever we're gonna heal forever
the difficulty spike yeah I'm healing myself I don't care
about the teammates here oh no all right heals I'm only
using the heals for myself.
Alright, we're good.
We just have to head up.
Get up here!
Get over your children!
The adults are in here yet, so I have an excuse to beat you
up!
Alright, I hope Jimmy has the napalm.
That's like my only hope right now.
Where do I go?
Did I kill everybody yet?
No, they're over there.
Alright.
healers this is a trick i just if i start healing next to it
i don't take five technically my heals negate the fire
damage that i took like look at this damage i'm doing it's
so sad it's actually so sad children please please this dark
banner it's not healthy Did we defeat everybody?
Is that everybody?
Oh my god, he's all the way over there!
Guys, my very real dragoons.
Okay, that's it.
This is it.
I'm gonna use my melee, my level 10 axe.
Wait, guys, I have a feeling.
Oh my god.
Guys, I just...
There's a possibility that my level 10 axe is really...
fucking strong.
I don't know.
It's just a theory.
It's just a theory that my axe could be really fucking
strong, but I'm not sure yet.
It's just a game theory, though.
It's just a game theory.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, this fucking tree, though.
Okay.
Kids!
Protect the queen!
Okay.
We just gotta kill this tree.
Oh, no.
Okay, nice.
She bet the barrier does not fucking work against melee.
I'm just gonna burn it for now.
Oh shit.
Alright, gotta get rid of the baby tree.
Baby tree, goodbye.
Okay, and then... Slam!
There you go.
Nice.
That should be everybody, right?
No!
One more!
Slam!
Okay, there you go.
We're good.
Level 10 axe, baby.
Axe and strong goes back to fire because it's like gun It's
almost like gun.
I can't stop myself In here off kid come on uh Raise the
rarity of the fire elemental card 70% additional damage
Fuck, okay 70% good choice.
I need more strength.
I'm like I feel so weak bring us together soon I feel so
fucking weak right now.
We need this Where do I go?
This way?
Oh, that's why they're so fucking strong.
Okay, that makes sense now.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
I was like, no wonder they hit so hard.
I was like, what the fuck?
Okay, we're good.
We're good now.
I do 70% more damage.
It's alright.
I have heals right next to me.
They can't aim.
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
I can heal again.
That's right.
Oh, okay.
Barrier.
All right, there we go.
I can heal again!
That's right!
I'll just stand here and take everything!
Player one?
You okay now?
Yeah, I'm pretty all right.
Wait, did I defeat everybody?
And they're all dead.
Yeah, they are.
All right, let me just heal.
More fire.
Okay, I need to heal myself so I can keep burning people.
Is that upgraded?
80%?
Alright, now I'm definitely stronger than melee.
Oh, fuck, where did you come from?
Where are my friends?
Oh, there you go.
My real friends.
Okay, we gotta burn him.
Alright, that's right.
Never have to use melee ever again.
that's really lucky though that i got like the that i got
the fucking 80 percent yeah i can just stand in front of you
dodge what's that no need to dodge real gamer hours real
gamer hours right here there you go we did it Can I unlock
it?
Where?
They're all dead.
Where are the enemies?
Abellion, thank you for attending.
Give the ships thank you.
Thank you.
Where the fuck are they?
Jimmy?
Is Jimmy here?
Is it Jimmy?
Where the fuck are the enemies?
Bro, this song is hardcore, though.
I'm not gonna lie.
This song is like...
It's so fucking hardcore for the situation I'm in.
Are you...
What?
Guys.
Mixed reviews.
But I want to know how the story ends.
The things I do for self-park.
Alright.
I mean, it's like five chapters, you know?
I might as well.
It's five chapters.
We're already past the two hours mark.
We're already past the two hours mark, so we might as well
try to see how the story ends.
How do I get out of here?
Oh, this way.
Alright, nice.
Here we go.
You think you're hot shit for getting through some of my
forces?
Guess what?
I got plenty more where that came from, you kids.
Oh my god, now I actually have to dodge.
No!
There's too many children!
Oh, what's the bullshit this time?
Projectile Hellstorm.
Whoa!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's okay.
We gotta kill all the bow and arrow kids.
It's all right.
I see you.
Ooh, it's okay.
Dodge.
Oh, wait.
Shield.
Oh!
Wait, you're not in bow and arrow.
You can do anything you want down there.
Except keep playing.
All right, that's okay.
That's okay.
My very real dragoons fell down so they can't res me.
Oh, I'm back.
I'm back.
Oh my god.
All right, there you go.
I'm just gonna stay here.
It's fine.
I'm gonna stay here.
Use my hues.
Get a little angie.
There you go.
Jesus Christ, these children.
These children need a fucking These children needs to get
checked to see if they're on any steroids.
Holy fuck.
What is this dark matter that makes them so strong?
I don't understand.
Like, what's making them so strong?
Dark matter should not...
You should be, like, in the bathroom right now.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Please.
Get her away from me.
Get her off me.
Get our off me.
Nice.
We did it.
We got a lot of dark matter.
Jimmy, please.
Jimmy.
Where are you, Jimmy?
Jimmy, do you have Napalm?
Who could have seen the Grand Wizard betraying us?
What is the problem?
No!
Okay, we need Napalm.
Rechuffle.
How about these?
Beefcake.
Increases your maximum.
Okay, no, not that.
that the bubble shield heals 2% health to all inside of it
what about me what I want you to heal me what about me
though you can upgrade we're at price oh we'll do beefcake
oh my god he doesn't have napalm but what about me I don't
care about my allies
it just says plus two for my allies it doesn't even say plus
me all right we're gonna grab some toilet paper that's okay
i got beef cake you're in the team there is no but it said
allies i don't know i don't trust it but there's
necromancers Oh, that's a forbidden spell.
Oh, you gotta kill those necromancers, dude, or they'll just
keep reviving the guys that you knocked out.
Which one?
Oh, friends!
Real dragoons help!
Player one?
All right.
It's okay, we're okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
All right, we got...
We gotta kill them.
Why am I...
Why do I only have two real dragoons?
It shouldn't matter.
what oh god okay here we go we got him oh my god get over
here get over here get over here mage necromancer you're
breaking the rules the fairy is a good part of fair all
parents never teach you anything all right we got we got rid
of one of them defeat all enemies into the rules.
Alright, nice.
Wait, is that also a Necromancer?
Yeah, he is.
Don't worry.
Spin to win.
Holy shit, I should have been fucking spinning since the
beginning.
Alright.
Up we go.
E.
We got E.
There has to be like...
We have to like fight the adults soon, I feel like.
Okay, there it necromancer don't worry i'm spinning spin
i'm gonna keep spinning spin no my spin oh not you not you
fuck this fuck this i'm gonna do it i've had enough i've had
enough get over over here.
I can't fucking see, but get over here.
Wait, is that the Necromancer?
No, the Necromancer is dead.
Alright, I'm gonna head over.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here, archers.
That's fucking right.
Spin to win.
You can't fucking run away from me.
You're...
You're projectile.
Alright, as long as the Necromancer is dead, so I don't have
to worry about them surviving him.
God, I should have been spinning this entire time.
Woo!
Alright.
Heels.
Alright, if you get close, I'm gonna spin.
If you get close to me, I'm gonna spin!
Oh, shit!
Alright.
I'm gonna spin!
Don't you dare!
Oh!
Whoa!
I'm sure someone will pick you up anytime.
Oh, no, NPC number four!
I can't...
No, we have to do that all over!
Are you kidding me?
Oh, no!
No way!
No fucking way!
Number four Dragoon, how could you?
How could you number four Dragoon?
I can't believe it It over for good There has to be somebody
on chapter 4 There has to be Okay Okay wait There has to be
There has to be somebody in chapter 4 Someone out there Must
still be playing It's okay dude Glad to have you back
Somewhere out there!
Wait, no, fuck, no, not this chapter.
Fuck, I went, I clicked any.
I clicked any, no!
Where am I?
You're here!
Maybe we can get something done now.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, I'm sorry, I'm leaving you.
I clicked the wrong one.
I chose any chapter.
There has to be somebody in chapter.
Chapter 4.
There has to be...
Alright.
Let's see.
Desire chapter.
Chapter 4.
You must be somewhere out there!
Bye, Lakisha.
I know you're out there.
I can't be the only one on Chapter 4.
Where am I?
Another warrior for me to defeat.
Hello!
Where is this?
What?
Where where is this?
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
I did it.
Yay All right, I'm leaving.
I'm sorry.
I don't understand.
I know I'm so good.
Kind of like how someone was like Colorado?
All right, we're gonna do spoilers off All right, join game
Avoid spoilers off Okay, chapter Because then I don't get
any cutscenes I think by clicking that I don't get any
cutscenes Okay, I'm back I want to see the cutscenes for
real This time
What?
No!
You're the only one on chapter 4 You cannot be the only one
you can There's no way how are you the only guy in chapter
four?
There's no way there's no way he's the only person in
chapter four The only person on there.
Okay.
All right Chapter four has to be a different guy at that
point The only other Canadian They have to be so confused Oh
my god Oh my god we did it Guys friends Hello I am here to
invade your session Let's go Oh my god I knew it I knew I'll
find real people We did it guys Let's go!
Look at that.
Real people.
I knew it.
I found friends.
Guys, I did it.
There's no way these guys can fuck it up.
There's no way.
Let's go.
Guys, I know where to go, guys.
It's this way.
There's no telling how strong they are.
Don't worry guys Come on get over here Guys get over here
guys Don't worry I'm playing Guys I know it says to the
number three But it's because like I decided to be generous
today Look at that Defeat all the enemies Don't worry guys
Oh my god we're actually We're actually in an area that I
can figure out lightning wait they like i have the chain
lightning shit oh shit that's so good i love the chain
lightning if we just need the napalm then we're fine oh no
we actually have the res it's okay the other players can res
i'm the dps unlimited power oh no i'm almost dead almost
unlimited power there you go we found the area though it's
all right somebody would res him right?
Like, somebody would eventually res that man, right?
We're good.
What the fuck?
Who did that?
Who the fuck?
Who the fuck is doing that?
Who is doing that?
I can't believe we found people.
Real people.
Oh, I got better chain lightning.
Alright, I guess we should revive him.
Who did that?
Who's doing that?
Okay, we gotta get rid of these guys.
Oh, look, he's back to normal.
Oh my god, I'm so paranoid.
Who's doing that?
I'm so fucking paranoid right now.
Wait, what?
Why are the dead?
Wait.
The dead can do that?
What?
Wait, what?
How come they didn't do that when I was playing?
Okay, I know that one was you.
I know that one was you number four.
Yeah, but why didn't they do that when I was playing the
game?
Oh, God, please, please, please, how do you turn it off?
Don't even bother resisting me, you guys.
You're playing by magic.
Oh, it's one of the cards.
Oh, that's a card.
But why?
What does that even do as a card?
I can't believe somebody played far enough to know that
that's what they...
That's a card.
Like, somebody has, like, has enough knowledge of the
Snowballs, the Snow Day game to know that's a fucking card.
How should you guys play to know that?
That's a good question.
Makes you go faster.
Alright, we gotta get the chain here.
Bro, this host keeps dying.
I'm the new captain now.
Don't res him!
Let him learn!
Let me be the new player one!
All right, we have to feed all of these guys.
How many someone was willing to play that far?
That's why I'm here.
I'm playing it this far so you guys don't have to.
All right, nice.
We killed everybody.
Nice.
We gotta go.
This way.
Jimmy!
Uh, Molotov cocktail.
Drops a Molotov.
Oh, is it worth it?
Molotov.
The 68...
Wait, no, the spin!
The legendary spin!
Try not to die.
That would be embarrassing.
Alright, we got it.
Let's go.
I'm ready.
I'm gonna spin.
Spin to win.
Okay, entering Main Street.
Alright, this is the part where I died.
I just got...
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, this game has mixed reviews and I sort of know why I
can't I sort of know why this game has mixed reviews It's
it's very obvious why wait what the fuck why didn't I why
didn't I do any damage to him?
Oh, there you go.
That was so weird.
I didn't do any damage just then Okay, I'm gonna heal a
little bit reviews were not wrong, that's for sure.
Like, I know why it's mixed reviews.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Don't worry, I'm spinning.
At least I can hold the charge up when I'm moving.
Just screw those guys and go home.
Alright, we're going.
Push up.
Push forward.
I need to go to the place where I die.
Keep pushing.
Oh, God.
There's the here.
Oh, it's because of the shield.
Oh, I understand.
I get it now.
There was a shield.
Oh, it must be a card or something.
Oh, no.
Oh, it's okay.
I'm okay.
I'm spinning.
I'm okay, guys.
I need to press an E here, though.
Guys, someone E.
Someone E.
You're
Spin!
Okay.
E!
We need all the E's!
Put all the heels right here in the center!
Double the heels!
We need double the heels!
Speed run!
Wait, what the fuck?
Alright.
We're okay.
Oh, this is good.
This is like...
No.
Not the bullshit.
Wait, what's that?
What's that?
What does that do?
What do I have?
I don't know.
This is not my session.
Oh, I'm taking damage, but I don't know what I'm doing.
What is it?
I want to know what my bullshit does.
Oh, I can run forever.
I could run forever.
Whoa.
No.
You can do anything you want down there.
My first death.
It's just like last game.
Oh.
Number two.
I'm so important.
Number four.
You know it.
It's all right.
Spin.
Just don't res number one.
we gotta establish a hierarchy here okay nice I got heal
that's alright we're good and then last guy what the fuck oh
it's a stealth guy Jimmy guys can you kill the last guy guys
I need to talk to Jimmy just one more guy come on just one
more you gotta got this i'm number one now oh nice
equimances maybe this will even the odds uh but but last two
percent two seconds more we deal and we deal very person oh
wait that's so good nice i'll take that i bid thee farewell
yeah you guys number one get over here god this is guys guys
this is why we have to kill number one like they're holding
us back He's holding us back and you see it.
Look at him.
He doesn't even have cred.
Come on.
Look at me.
Look at you.
You have cred.
I have cred They're holding us back and you know it.
You know it They are those Yeah, but that's only their job
Being the host doesn't make you special and you have to earn
number one.
Wait, where do we go?
Survive all the waves.
Where are the waves?
Oh, there they are.
There are the waves.
Don't worry, I'm heading over.
Spin!
Don't worry.
The moment I keep spinning, spin!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, no, oh, no, oh, no, oh, no.
Spin!
Oh, my god!
This is such an OP attack.
This is actually so OP.
Holy shit.
I put shields and then I spin.
Hey.
Don't worry.
Bubbles!
Spin!
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
That's a lot of people.
You're getting carried.
You're all getting carried.
You're getting carried by a real gamer.
I played on hard difficulty.
This is baby.
This is baby level.
Okay, got to get the bubble dough.
Alright.
Spin!
Let it rip.
It's like Beyblade all over again.
Oh, God, please!
Last guy!
The last one!
Wait, no.
Wait, is that really?
Is there more?
Where's the other...
Oh, over there.
On me!
You can't hear me, but on me!
Bade Blade.
It's time to Bade Blade.
We have what... Please get me out of here.
We just have...
We have two more chapters left.
We're so close.
We're so close to finishing this game!
Spin!
Alright, now I actually zap, because I actually don't know
where they are.
I lost track of people.
They're going way too fast.
I can't be bothered to chase after them.
I can't be bothered to chase after this fucker.
Alright.
It's all the fucking stealth elves.
Bro, you're not cool!
Alright.
We gotta help.
We gotta help these two.
Alright.
It's time!
For my secret weapon!
Woo!
This is like babies of urban time, I think.
All right.
All I'm going to say, never go out of the formula.
Let it rip.
Oh, God.
No, not the sixth graders.
It's okay.
They can't jump up here, so I'm fine.
They...
Oh, what?
You're not even the sixth graders.
I'm stunned forever.
I'm...
Oh, God.
Oh, oh, I got poisoned.
I definitely got poisoned.
Alright.
So, we have double healers.
Okay.
I gotta get rid of the 6th graders here.
Ow.
Wait, he's, like, shooting his own people.
Stop the bleeding.
Kill yourself.
I don't need heals.
Oh.
Okay, maybe I do.
Maybe.
Maybe I do need this.
Where the fuck is the last guy?
Did we survive it?
Great job, new kid.
Oh my god, we fucking did it.
We fucking did it.
Oh.
We survived.
We made it.
See anything like?
Alright, let's see.
Rubber bubble.
It deals 8 damage to the attacker.
Do I risk it?
risk it.
I might have Napal.
God damn it.
Wait, I can risk it again.
How do these look?
Come on, Jimmy.
Don't fuck with me, Jimmy.
That's the one?
Great.
I guess I'll think of the team.
I'm rooting for you.
I guess.
I guess I'll think of the team.
Hey, new kid, get ready.
Eric must be close.
There's Eric
I lost the gotcha I did All right, Eric, there's Cartman.
We're gonna catch you and you're ruining the game You're the
one ruining the game.
What the fuck do you mean?
You're the one that's fucking up the game There's rules to
this.
I'm skipping everybody I'm gonna head over I went the wrong
way.
Why did you guys follow me?
It was actually this way.
It's okay.
Find the traitor.
That's Carmen.
We already know who the traitor is.
It's okay.
Four and not three knows what's up.
I still don't know what this does.
What does this do to me?
What the fuck does this do to me?
We had to defeat them anyway This is fucked up We had it
didn't matter It didn't fucking matter We had to kill them
anyway Okay See yeah Oh I do heal I am an ally I'm ally Okay
don't worry I've spin Speed I can kill like three at the
same time which is great.
This is so good for me.
Okay, Q.
Q.
Oh, God.
Please stop.
Please.
Alright.
Can we do it?
No, there's one guy left.
Stop!
I know it's one of you guys!
I know it's one of you.
Stop!
I swear to God, please!
Now you're gonna get it.
Stop!
Alright, we gotta get Carmen now.
Mom!
The new kid's trying to ruin my snow day time!
One minute, poopsiekins.
I just need to dab on a little more Christmas magic.
Oh no.
Not the Christmas mat.
Not the adults!
I can cry about it, Kyle, you little bitch!
Oh!
Holy shit!
Bro!
Bro, the- this is serious.
This is actually serious.
It's okay, I can spin.
This is why you get the doki-kiri.
Bam!
Instant.
Wait, we did it!
Wait, we killed him!
So fucking easy.
I- I- I don't understand!
I don't understand why, like, this host has this fucking
lobby.
Bro, the adults can actually kill you.
Alright, where do we go?
Oh, we have to go...
Actually, oh my gosh, there's more adults?
There's more adults?
The adults gonna break my back!
Alright, here you go.
You're gonna start grounding me!
Where are you?
bro she's like one fucking kill stealer okay I'm gonna grab
the arrows all right fuck this I'm using it I'm gonna
fucking fly you oh what come on I'm trying to fucking I'm
trying fucking spin there you go nice is that everybody who
else is left I can fly forever now I almost got bade.
Bro, bro, it's no joke.
She can actually bade me.
Bro, I'm a child.
You fucking...
Press my head.
You pressed the wrong spot in my head.
I fucking die.
That shit is serious.
Come on, come on.
It's gotta be another way out of here.
Oh, there's a carbon.
There's carbon right over here.
Holy shit.
He has venom powers.
The hell is I don't think God will want us fighting around
his house like this.
Where is he?
Where's the fuck his car?
No, no, it's this again.
All right, get out of your fucking force field.
Get out of your fucking force field.
Get over here.
Get over here, you fucking archer.
Nice.
Oh my god, I need you guys to group up more.
I'm wasting my attack on one person.
I really need you guys to group up more.
Shield.
Oh, thank god.
area.
That's what I like.
3-4-1 special.
See you guys?
I'm hopeful.
I don't know how I always get tricked into...
I always know that like every time Carmen runs it means he
has to...
It means like I have to defeat all the enemies but every
time it gets me.
Every time I forgot about that and I just run into like five
different all right wait there he is oh he was a fucking
clone i'm so op right now okay we need to go over here are
you good it's cartman time finally carbon get over here take
me to the next area hey what the bro it's not fair okay it's
fine one and two one and two can handle these guys
we run so one and two can handle the rest of the people all
right get over here we had to defeat the sniper all right up
we go jimmy no who's still alive boy go and get them i'm
wait at jimmy's place i believe in you four go do your thing
i'll be right here
bro what the come on it's one guy i only got two and i are
just like whatever um look i already did my job okay did you
not see me kill the three adults come on there's still two
more it's okay well they'll be fine
They'll be fine.
Look, I can't keep doing everything, chat.
I'm not gonna do everything.
Let's just...
Yeah.
Let's go, too.
You know what I mean, too.
Let's go.
What the fuck is one doing?
Bro, can one aim?
I think one is, like, not doing so well.
Yeah.
Oh, I got the zombie shuffle dance.
What is this?
The moving.
I like how this is called the moving grooving when it's the
Snoopy dance.
They'll be fine.
I'm not gonna get kicked.
They know.
They know that I am the carry.
They won't kick me out because I'm the carry.
The poison.
Molotov.
Look.
Here, try these on the side.
I want to see if I can get legendary.
God damn it.
Oh, okay.
20% bigger.
That's always good.
See you soon.
All right, I'm ready.
Let's go.
Let's go, too.
Come on.
Nice.
I got big, bubba.
Big.
Hey, the carter is more Carmen, please I know this one, you
know, this is not realistic because Carmen would never run
this far
This is not realistic Carbo would never be up that mountain
He'd be like it would have been done after like the first
two areas
How dare you oppose the grand wizard?
It's just because he really doesn't want to go.
He really doesn't want to go to school.
Unrealistic.
Carbon would never walk so far.
What is this?
Oh god, what the fuck?
Get over here.
You're literally one.
My axe is not long enough.
He fucking went up the fucking roof.
all that for the room all right where the fuck okay get out
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god I'm okay I'm okay
I'm okay oh he's gone he's gone
He's gone.
He can't hurt me no more.
He can't hurt me anymore.
Holy shit.
I got fucking soft blocked so hard.
You went down that road.
Regretting it, aren't you?
They always do.
Alright.
Hey, Goff.
Hey, Goff kid.
Raise the level of all your upgrade cards.
Raise the rarity of the chain lightning card.
Uh, I'm gonna raise the level.
That's powerful.
So I can have bigger spins.
new kid all right it's time it's time guys
oh this is it this is it
it's time to kill kartman come on you must have known you
were disposable and lucky for me mr hanky gave me some of oh
no kartman no kartman that's not good for you
Oh, no, you don't want Mr. Hanky to attack the real Cartman.
Oh!
Oh, God.
This force field!
I'm trying to hit him.
I'm trying to head towards him.
Wait, he gets to have a force field too?
What the fuck?
Oh, no, he doesn't get a force field.
That's like, that's just his...
Oh, that's just his projectile thing!
Oh, God.
How is he so strong?
Who gave... Who let him have the illegal spells?
Where did he go?
Oh my god, he's over there.
He's over there Okay, don't worry.
I'm spinning.
He doesn't get sucked up into my fucking spells.
Oh, no, someone revive him!
Okay, nice.
I know which one is the real grand wizard.
I got the cue.
Where is he?
Please Where's the real wizard he saves as he's using the
force fields?
God damn it you can't knock it off.
Where is he?
I'm fucking using those bro?
He doesn't get sucked up into my force field So that's not
fair.
Oh New kids you have disobeyed the grand wizard.
Where is he?
The laws of Zaron.
Oh, he was right behind me this entire time Bro, this is so
hard So if he's that difficult how difficult is mr.
Hinky?
okay all right there you go I'm just gonna use change
lightning this is not good where are you one again where did
he go they played a phone weapons card new kid your close
range attacks do minus damage which one is he which one is
he which one's the real Cartman that's not the real Cartman
oh no he's the one that's running he's the fat ass get over
here fat ass no he's not the one running oh my god I can't
figure it out we killed so many of them where are they
that's the last one it has to be him it's him it's him it's
him you can't Okay, I have a barrier too.
That's fucking right.
Oh, no, it's a noodle arms.
Oh, no.
Come on!
Barrier!
Alright.
God damn it.
He keeps using barrier!
How can he be so angry?
He's one, he's one, he's one!
Nice.
Oh, thank you.
God thank fucking God thank fucking God we did it guys we
defeated Cartman we fucking did it one more chapter left
look at me go oh my god look at that Butcher!
Most enemies eliminated!
I knew I was gaming.
I fucking knew I was gaming.
I knew I was carrying chat!
Guys, we're at the final stretch.
We're almost there.
Stage strong, everybody.
Okay, uh, everyone have a nice dinner?
Man, I am stuffed.
I hate too much.
So, Kube, uh, back to the game, I guess.
I believe we are about to join forces in battle of Mr.
Hanky, right?
Fuck you, Cartman.
We're not playing with you anymore.
Yeah, you tried to kill us with Dark Matter.
You're out of the game.
Well, except you can't kick me out of the game because I'm
the Grand Wizard.
So?
Why can't we have a new Grand Wizard?
We know you're not going to help because you still don't
want to go back to school.
He's right.
You were pretty adamant about not wanting to go back to
school.
Well, I've changed my mind.
The truth is none of this is my fault.
I think we all know whose fault it is.
Whose fault is it?
Me?
It's been just a shit show of rules breaking and I got
caught up in it all the time.
But we have to find Mr. Hanky and stop this storm.
It's not my fault you guys are all bad at the game.
We should let him play.
He just wants to join us so he can betray us again.
I want to join you because that's the ruse.
The losing clan has to join forces with whoever defeated
them, right?
That's your rule, Kyle.
And I understand how important rules are because if we don't
have rules, then the new kid's just gonna ruin the game like
always.
He's got a point there.
What did I do?
We have to take Mr. Hanky down before more people die.
It's not my fault.
I'm just a better gamer than all
year how is that my fault if we survive this i'm totally
kicking your ass cartman what did i do i'm kicking his ass
first your leader chooses the next mission but you can go
get me some hot cocoa all right let's see if we have oh we
have everything unlocked now much untapped that sees enemy
and explodes after a short delay wait that's so that sounds
so cool that seeks enemies and you just pick one okay we
don't need heals My team will heal for me.
Tell your friends.
That's alright.
My team will heal for me.
Look at that.
Now I have drones.
We've got clothes.
Alright, we need the dark matter too.
Alright, dark matter time.
No!
They kicked me out!
Let's call that one a training.
No!
I have one more, please!
I replaced right here.
They kicked me out.
I don't understand.
what did they kick me out I was carrying I was carrying
there has to be somebody there there has to be somebody on
the final game there has to be somebody playing the final
chapter someone out there you're in the cutscene why can't I
watch what is this leaving I'm gonna use the bathroom I'll
be right back
I can't be right back.
All right, I'm back.
All right.
I can't believe.
I can't believe nobody is...
Okay, we're just gonna...
Okay, here's the plan, chat.
You guys want to try playing elves sometime?
We're gonna watch the...
We're gonna watch the cutscene from the beginning.
And then...
How come...
How come that fucker...
I'm so mad.
How come that person gets to have...
gets to have four players and then i get one real player
like it's so not fair how did they get four people to join
them and i get one like they weren't even good this is
bullshit this is actual Bullshit.
This is actual bullshit.
This person got four people to join.
Three people to join them.
The Grand Wizard now returned from his temporary, but
totally understandable madness.
The assault on Mr. Hanks' fortress.
I was part of that group!
He's the chosen one, your number four.
You guys, one at a time, guys.
hero thank you for the five give the ships thank you thank
you hey guys don't wait up there's still 33 seconds to join
me don't don't wake up everybody we're almost there whoa
okay we're all here let's go wait no we're not guys come on
don't you don't want to miss the cutscene.
Guys, dragoons, you don't want to miss the cutscene.
You're still playing this game.
Look, I'm playing this game to completion so that you guys
can see the ending of this game and you don't have to buy
it.
I'll say it now.
I'm indie.
This game, it's mixed reviews for a reason.
It's only for my love of Soapark that I'm willing to play to
the end.
I Wait, don't buy this game.
Don't buy this game.
Mr. Hickey, why are you doing this?
You used to be our friend.
Yeah, until you kicked me out of town.
Yeah, but he got canceled.
He canceled me and made me an outcast.
And all I did was text him in and tweet a couple bad jokes.
They weren't just bad jokes.
They were really racist and homophobic jokes.
That were pretty funny.
The worst part is, you boys weren't there for me.
My own friends.
They just turned their back.
No, you turned your back on us, Mr. Henke.
We're not going to let you keep destroying South Park.
Reverse the spell now.
Stop this endless winter, or we're going to have to end it
ourselves.
You're too late.
This town and Amber Green is tasting my dark matter.
I'm in control now.
All I needed was one of you to use my dark magic and build
up its power.
I'd put my money on Stan, but he fucked it up.
And I had to settle for that lame new kid.
turd dresses and his stupid face what so lame but with my
but i paid 20 extra dollars i have the season pass by the
way you know that these guys are just using you right i have
the season pass though of this amazing game
he's mocking my cred it's like he's completely lost his
christmas spirit the final battle begins They have the
priest.
I have the pre-order privilege.
Alright.
Last wave.
Once, I understand.
Are you saying Mr. Hanky the Christmas poo came out of
Jesus's butthole?
Wait, what?
The holiest.
That is the power you're dealing with.
So beware his wrath.
I want to be able to summon people.
What do I have?
What does Mr. Hanky have?
Holy protection.
Be gone, projectiles!
Are you serious?
What?
Piercing coal.
Retaliation blast.
I can't believe this trash.
They get...
They get so many fire arrows and ice arrows?
Hey, no kid.
Don't believe what Mr. Hanky said.
said about you know us using you and stuff yeah we're not
using you you're our friend whoa yeah because we're friends
and not because you're way more powerful than all of us
we're friends okay you're not leeching off of me we're
actually friends
thank you lord hell's past hospital guys see i have friends
i told you guys I have real friends, guys.
Guys, look.
I knew they were real.
I knew they were real people.
I knew they I knew it.
Chad, I told you.
Told you they're real.
Alright, down we go.
Wee.
Are you friends?
Friend?
Oh!
There you go He just ran from me guys What happened to my
real people my real friends?
Oh my god.
There you guys are Real friends We've been waiting for you.
You can't there you are guys.
I knew you were real How did from four?
How did they leave?
How did my real friends left me?
Oh god I liked how I liked how like Three of like two of
them left Like my very real friend Like how you're not even
actually real Fuck this I'm sending in the drone Alright
guys I have an idea Guys we're gonna return to the Akupa
keep Now that we saw The cutscene We're gonna do an epic
gamer move.
Watch this.
Now that we know what the cutscene is, it's time.
It's time for the real gamer move.
Right here.
The pro gamer strap.
Please don't be in any cutscene.
Hey guys.
Oh shit.
Are you just starting the new chapter too?
Me too.
Let's go.
Hey guys.
Wait, did you just finish it?
Wait, no, they just finished the game.
I think they just finished it.
This is the one.
No, there's no way.
Okay, wait, I think they actually just finished it.
There's no way.
Because like, why is it daytime?
Why is it daytime?
I don't understand.
This is it.
There's has to be somebody on chapter four.
There has to, or chapter five.
You're, you're out there.
You're out there.
And
you again bro why is there no one in your lobby there's no
one you're in the same chapter as me there's nobody here
there's no way you have to exist you have to exist okay
maybe if i put normal maybe if i you can't be on normal it's
you again
all right okay guys guys we're just testing a theory we're
just testing a theory chat No way!
If I'm on easy and it's him again, there's no no game was
found!
He's like, he's actually the only one!
Oh my god, oh my god, it can't be the same person.
Oh my god!
I knew it!
Don't worry!
I got quid it's okay guys it's okay oh I am your new friend
you're curious I broke the loop I broke the loop chat we did
it we fucking broke the loop I can't believe it guys we
fucking did it oh my god we broke the fucking loop
oh my god it's just where i left off too it's like i would
have liked it if they were a little bit ahead but like why
would you play on hard and do this to yourself you played
the other four chapters i think what i'm most surprised is
the fact that these guys are willing to play hard On on on
the last chapter after going through hard on the other
chapters That's what I'm most impressed by
Kit cannon oh no not the kids So Joki thoughts on this game.
I know why this game is There's a reason why this game has
mixed reviews and And it's it's very reasonable.
It's actually a So fucking reasonable.
It is such a reasonable choice.
Oh my god.
I'm playing this game right now to the end.
So you guys will not play to the end.
So you guys will know what it's like.
Oh my god.
Where do we go?
Do you guys know where to go?
Do we oh wait fight your way to the top?
But how do we get to the top?
They go through oh wait to go through the hospital.
There's way more shit up there.
You'll want an upgrade Okay, what what do we not defeat?
All right, you guys go do your thing I'm just here to leech
I want to I want to know what what the fucking ending is You
guys got this
right now.
Alright, let's see.
The drone no longer moves, but deals 30% more damage?
Wait, how is that better?
Willow shield is 20% bigger and that's 12?
Okay, I feel like that's better.
Please don't kick me.
I struggled so hard to get here.
Don't worry, I've got enough upgrades for everyone.
Alright, we need some toilet paper.
Don't kick me, guys.
I worked so hard to be here.
Where do we go?
We have to wait for it.
Did everybody upgrade it?
Yeah, that's me.
I'm the new kid.
Where do we go?
Who still hasn't upgraded?
Three!
Hurry the fuck up!
I'm number two!
That means I'm next in succession!
Hey, where's the global warming when we need it, huh?
Wow, what a great audience.
What the fuck, Jimmy?
Oh, there it is.
There's a chest.
What's this?
Oh, bubble shield is bigger.
Oh, shit!
I'm stunned.
I'm stunned and I'm bleeding.
Don't worry.
I'm sending out the drones.
The drones are gonna do stuff.
I go down?
I know it says fight your way to the top.
But I'm gonna head down.
all right oh nice i got when hit the bubble games two
seconds and make you more pissed off nice that's my favorite
oh wait they're already dead wait what did i did i go the
wrong way i did oh no guys don't kick me i just went the
wrong way i'm heading to the right way now all right here Do
not worry!
I'm going to contribute!
I'm here to contribute to the team!
Wait, these guys are actually pretty good!
Oh my god, they already killed so many people!
Wait a minute!
This is a team!
This is a team right there!
Where else do we go?
Oh, hey, more chest.
Nice.
We got the chest.
Come on, guys.
Right here.
Follow me.
Dude, I just realized something.
Dark magic is shit.
This whole time, we've been smearing shit on ourselves.
Oh, sad.
Now you know.
I just decided not to think about it.
Because I'm so gross.
Not as gross as going back to school.
Sad.
Now you realize.
Guys, it's Mr. Hink.
What else would it be?
It's literally Mr. Hanky.
Oh god.
I need to realize that this is a team game.
Let me go.
Okay.
Drone time.
Drone.
Keep droning.
Keep droning!
drone a win drone a win there we go I hope my drone is doing
something I have no idea I really hope my drone is actually
working I almost like blame somebody else okay bubble time
okay we gotta go drone drone all right nice got some more
I'm gonna kill this guy get over here get over here sniper
we're almost to the top one more sixth graders we just gotta
kill the last six I got you I got the sniper get over here
sniper oh my god i was so fucking spoiled by the legendary
nice i was really spoiled by the legendary spin please
please please why is it every time i joined somebody else's
session everyone in south park will do whatever i tell them
just for a hit of my sweet christmas magic jimmy now this is
what i call a climax ready for your last upgrade oh my god
oh my god the last
I'm so ready I'm so ready The last upgrade Please Alright
Your health total is set But with 10% less stamina Okay we
need more That looks pretty good Bubba The last one Try not
to die That would be embarrassing Guys We're gonna make it
Crazy weather we had We fucking survived The last one we're
gonna make it oh my god the last upgrade we're gonna make it
everybody we're so close to the finish line drone drone
drone drone drone drone please explode okay guys I think I
have a feeling that the drone is not that strong I realized
that possibly the drone that was not as strong as I thought
it was.
It's making me a little sad that I got the drone.
Oh, you think you're hot shit?
The drone is a little weak.
Yeah.
The drone kind of sucks, guys.
Why did nobody stop me from getting a drone?
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Why did nobody... That's all the damage it does?
Wow, player four.
That's actually all the damage it does on the drone.
That's why the one I chose to put my dark matter inside of
was you.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, let's go.
We're almost there.
Team, we're almost at the finish line.
We can't get a refund because we've committed.
We've committed to seeing the end.
Team, this is it.
The end is so near.
four hours of this of our lives please where the fuck is the
other guy where is he did he fall down there he is i don't
think he knows we're here we have to strike okay new kid
you're the one with all the dark magic go ahead kill mr
hanky no no wait what if this is a trap what if mr hanky
needs a human boy filled with dark magic to strike him down
so that their power is like mixed with his powers and he can
rise up and become even more powerful than ever wait that's
pretty smart, Cartman.
Wait, no.
Wait, he's spinning facts.
I already put so much dark matter inside me.
I'm just gonna do that.
Oh!
Guys, he absorbed four dark matters.
You thought I was asleep, but I was listening.
I just needed a human child to get super OP and pissed off
and then use their dark matter against me.
you guys now I'll be unstoppable oh great job new kid you
fucked us you guys shouldn't listen to me why I wasn't the
one that fucked you guys it was the other new kids I wasn't
that strong use your bullshit can't believe it Carmen was
finally right he's right one of ten times their offerings
for the great one dark Christmas is upon us and he has taken
his final Yeah, what are you talking about?
Yeah, what the fuck are you talking about?
What?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, is that the final form that I spoiled myself with
because I was trying to like cheese this?
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
The part where like they're like they're in the cutscene,
you can't fucking watch it with them.
There's only one way to deal with a bunch of shit.
Yeah, toilet paper.
There's a ton of it here.
Great.
We can use those cannons to shoot it at him.
Come on, let's go.
Yankee's true for it.
It's okay.
We have to use the toilet paper.
Oh my god, they're babies.
Oh, shit.
Cannons will fire without TP.
Find a pack and bring it there.
I'm trying.
Oh, where the fuck?
Can I change?
I got him.
Oh, there's two.
many again all right okay i'm gonna submit an army that's
lasers that wasn't an army that was lasers okay i'm helping
guys drone drone all right i'm gonna grab you guys the
toilet paper you guys do all the other work come on where's
your business don't worry i'll help you guys get the toilet
paper
Don't worry, I'm the bait!
There you go!
Grab it!
Oh, God!
Guys, I think I need heals.
Guys, I think I need heals, guys.
I might have messed up.
I might have messed up and thought I did not need heals.
Oh, fuck, okay.
We gotta...
Oh, no!
I need red suit!
guys i'm not okay i'm not okay oh thank god okay i believe
in you guys i'm gonna stay here next to the hues oh no oh no
he's gonna fucking hidey-ho me okay get over here get over
here i got i got him i got him i got the toilet paper I can
jump with the toilet paper too.
Oh, shit.
Okay, here we go.
I'm heading over.
I'm going to be helpful for once in my life.
I'm not going to leech off.
I'm going to be helpful.
Here we go.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo,
yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo,
I got to bury up.
he has the toilet paper don't worry i'm gonna get the crap
oh you can do anything you want hey guys i'm also very
important hey everybody hey guys psych yoink here we go nice
no are you fucking kidding me oh there he is no okay we
gotta wait we gotta wait Where is he?
Oh, no, he's gonna beat.
Where is he?
Come on.
I'm holding it.
No!
Oh, oh, he hasn't hurt me.
He has to show up here.
It's alright.
They're just hiding.
No, it's not okay.
They damaged it.
You fucking...
I was literally holding it in.
Dodge.
Oh, she got the toilet paper.
Yes, ma'am.
Where's the other toilet paper?
Where is it?
Why is there a toilet paper up there?
Who's going to be able to grab it?
What is he looking at?
What is this?
Oh, I got slow motor some shit.
Oh, God.
Please.
Take me to the other.
I just want to touch this toilet paper.
Yes!
Guys, please.
I'm not a detriment to this team.
I just need you all to know that.
I just need you all to know.
I am trying my best right now.
I am trying my best here.
Unless there's...
Oh, no.
My team is so smart.
I'm like the distraction.
I'm bait.
I'm just what the fuck happened to me what the fuck I got
gang banged by a bunch of poop like what the fuck Hey guys
an important member here number two It's okay, I got my I'm
just bait I'm just bait Here we go We're fine We did it Oh
my god I existed I Guys we did it guys Oh my god What a team
What a fucking team Oh What a team chat What a beautiful
team You picked up a bunch of dark murder How's that buddy
They're so good.
We're all so good, Chad.
We're all...
We did it.
They wouldn't have made it there without me.
The storm has lifted.
The snow is melting.
And toilet paper is once again just for wiping your butt.
Things are going back to normal in South Park.
And we're all gonna be alright.
All of us except for the thousands who tragically lost
their...
Let's see.
all right back to you tom i've just been told that tom has
also tragically lost his life no not tom back to you kelly
was your report the news
it's not that big a deal karmic what about me we all have to
go you know not that long ago i prayed to god and all i
asked was to not get totally back school isn't that bad dude
no no it's okay i'm pretty used to getting fucked now it's
just sort of hard for the course when you have faith in a
higher power who the is that that can't be hanky we killed
him jesus jesus oh my god my children i am very disappointed
in all of you what wait what in all of us all of us what do
we do Mr. Hanky brought you happiness and joy and yet when
he got cancelled for his Twitter posts You would not forgive
him No, that was everyone else in town.
We didn't care and yet did you stand by Mr. Hanky's side
when everyone turned on him Everyone made mistakes Just
because it's Jesus Someone requested the skip by the way
Yeah
Oh, come on.
Mr. Hanky?
Whose toilet does he live in?
We should have had your back.
Yeah, we should have had each other's backs.
I'll just talk about the rules, what's wrong and right.
Yeah, if anyone's been a piece of shit, it's been us.
You guys don't mean it.
yeah yeah we beat it really we messed up too mr hanky
everybody does this like feels good or gets to orchestra
music oh my god well thank you boys this is the best day of
my life now we just got to figure out how to get the rest of
the town to forgive you i don't care what the town thinks of
me so long as i have you kids oh great now we can all be
friends again and maybe sometimes just sometimes you can
make a blizzard again so we can have another snow day yeah
maybe like right now could you mr hanky can we just have
like one more snow day one more snow day so we can have more
dungeons and dragons yeah time to kill another thousand
people yeah
one more time one more time oh you're loaded with dark
matter we did it i was gonna ask is there an after credit
scene but i don't think there's enough people to know if
there's an after credit scene i can't i can't tell i don't
think there's enough people to fucking figure this out out
what about the new kid we just forgot about the new kid
lobster thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh
my god what a fucking journey all right okay i love trey
parker matt stone and like i love like the stuff they do
like i even went to the book of mormon musical with the
original cast and got like, I bought like VIP seat, like not
VIP, sorry, like some of the best seats for Book of Mormon
because it was like one of the musicals.
I've always wanted to watch.
And I was like in New York at, like I was in New York at the
time for, for like a conference, like an academic
conference.
So I was lucky enough to see the Book of Mormon with the
original cast, you know, before they all went become stars
in their own right.
And I love, like, all the stuff they do.
I love, like, when they were the guy, one of them, when they
did the voice acting for one of the despicable me movies.
That was pretty fucking funny.
But, like, holy fuck, this game, this game was a fucking
chore to play.
This game, I...
i took a risk and a gamble to play this game on launch
because i was like okay i had a feeling it won't be like the
perfect game because it's like this weird this is a new area
they're gonna play they're like there's a new area they
wanted to explore but oh my god oh my god
I think it just it just needed something it felt really
repetitive the longer the longer you play it the it got like
more and more repetitive so like it just needed something
more it just it really needed something more it felt like
really fucking repetitive oh my god but we did it Guys, we
fucking did it.
I can't believe zero.
When I try to queue up for easy, zero game.
Zero players were playing.
That was actually crazy.
There was nobody playing a game on easy.
And one guy on normal.
Oh, we cleared it.
We fucking did it.
all the way to the end i wanted to play all the way to the
end but oh my god
what a journey that was i'm just happy we made it to the end
chat i'm so happy we made it
ggs everybody ggs i play this game so you guys don't have to
i had to i wanted to go all the way to the end so you guys
don't have to i know it might not have been like the most
engaging stream to watch but thank you for sticking it
through with me thank you when i got to okay at first i was
like okay i'm gonna play two chapters i'm just gonna play
two chapters and then i'm gonna call it there and then never
touch the game again but then i played two chapters and then
the thing is we were past the two hour mark after the two
chapters so then i was like all right fuck it there's
nothing i can do i might as well play it to the end and get
my money's worth because i pre-ordered the deluxe version i
was like i i like i i got through the i was like oh my god i
might as well i pre-ordered it got the Okay.
Okay.
The funniest thing.
The funniest thing was that I saw that.
What was his name?
I saw.
Was it Nogla?
Like I saw like.
Fuck.
Was it Nogla that had like early access to this game?
And I was like.
I'm going to watch this a little bit.
So I know.
Not Nogla.
Fuck.
What's his name?
Oh yeah.
No.
Like Nogla.
like his friends um who was this the other who was the other
guy that also got like venasin everybody uh god what was
like i'm trying to remember oh yeah delirious yeah uh
terrorizer delirious and no good they got like sponsored by
they got they got sponsored by this game and i was watching
it a little bit because i was like oh early access and then
I was like, okay, because I was like, oh, hey, they're
streaming early access, like the early release copy of the
fucking game.
And then I was watching it.
I was, I watched five minutes.
And then they were like, this is the best game we've ever
played.
They were like, they were like, oh my God, this is so fun.
I, oh my God, guys, this is so fucking fun.
This is one of the best I'm like, bro.
Like, oh my god, this is so fucking fun, guys.
I was like, oh my god, isn't actually that fun?
No, they were.
They were sponsored.
So, like, it's understandable.
But, like, I, bro, I like, I was like, I believed it a
little bit.
I was like, okay.
because I I was like oh man I was hesitant I that was I
watched the early copy and that's why I bought the deluxe
version I bought the I pre-ordered the deluxe version
because I was like oh my god maybe it's not that bad because
I was worried I was like oh man I'm worried me I fell for it
I actually fell for it because they actually sounded really
exciting excited they were they actually sounded so excited
I fucking fell for it um
I fucking I fucking fell for the sponsor I was like oh my
god they sound like they're actually having so much fun so
so because that was what pushed me to pre-ordering the
deluxe version over like the normal copy like I was like do
I get the deluxe copy or do I because I was like okay if I
get the normal copy I'll just do like I just like play the
first two chapters and then call looked at fun as fun as
like the other games their older games and then and then
like and then i watched their sponsored stream i watched
five minutes of their sponsored stream and that was the
moment where they were like oh my god this game is so fun
and i was like oh my god maybe it is so fun so then i was
like all right i'm going i'm i am going to risk it i'm gonna
risk it i fell for I fell for it when you want to believe
the thing is when the creators when the creators actually
like take control like take creative control they can make
really really really good things like like like uh the
creators of self-park when they have majority of the
creative control they're really good at making really good
games or really good shows or really good like But I don't
know what happened to this game.
I don't know what happened to this game.
Like, they had creative controller.
So, like, what the fuck happened?
Like, what?
Yeah.
Yeah, Trey and Matt.
I was so surprised.
Because usually they do really well.
Like, the...
The...
The Stick of Truth and, like, the Fractured Butthole.
Those are really good...
I mean, I haven't played Fractured Butthole, but I heard it
was a really good game, too.
they were really good and then like the musical stuff that
was really good what the fuck happened here what happened
I'm so sad it was made by a different studio maybe I think
the 3D oh no different dev team I guess yeah the studio says
gullible on the dokey look many thank you this super chat
thank you thank you yeah but like i don't know i trusted i
trusted i trusted the creators because like usually when
they're head of the creative team um they work really hard
in trying to make a good game so i was i was just surprised
that it was just mid it was so mid it was it's not like
super shitty it was just really mid It was incredibly mid.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
I'm pretty tired.
That game really took a lot out of me.
So, but I hope you guys still enjoyed your time with me
today.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.